des solidarités et de la santé à l'au
d'une crise sanitaire sans précédent je
sais ce que je lui dois je sais ce qu'il
apporte à notre pays et je le remercie
avec
reconnaissance je voudrais aussi avoir
un mot pour les premiers ministres qui
m'ont accordé leur confiance Édouard
Philippe Jean Castex ellisabeth borne
j'ai beaucoup appris à leur côté la
France s'est dotée d'un nouveau Premier
ministre et je le dis avec la plus
grande conviction nous avons de la
chance beaucoup de chance alors longue
vie et plein succès à Gabri à la tale et
son
gouvernement ma chère
Priska ton parcours tes convictions tes
engagements suffise à faire de toi la
bonne personne au bon endroit au bon
moment aux amis on donne habituellement
des conseils mais en l'occurrence tu
n'en as pas besoin tu as tous les atouts
pour réussir dans ce poste tu connais le
monde des médias son exigence son
professionnalisme la France a d'ailleurs
de la chance de pouvoir compter sur des
journalistes aussi rigoureux aussi
passionnés par leur mission celle
d'informer les
citoyens aussi si tu m'y autorises pris
je souhaite profiter de ces dernières
minutes comme ministre pour m'adresser
choses inhabituelles à mes enfants parce
que je ne les ai pas beaucoup vu grandir
ces qu dernières années et que je vaux
leur transmettre ici un peu de ce que
j'ai moi-même compris et parce que
finalement les enfants de son pays sont
l'avenir de notre
démocratieenez
à
écouter celui qui vous parle vous fait
un cadeau si vous savez entendre des
nombreuses rencontres que j'ai eu la
chance de vivre avec les Français à
travers tout le pays partout le même
constat si le lien qui nous unit est
encore fort nous devons en prendre soin
nous ne devons pas relâcher l'effort la
confiance fait place à la défiance à
force à force de ne pas écouter la
défiance conduite à la colère à force de
ne pas se parler en politique cela
nourrit la haine envers les institutions
et ceux qui les portent et ça les
populistes sen repaent dans la vie c'est
la conduite à l'isolement à la solitude
cela rend pas plus heureux nous avons
tous les atouts pour collectivement
renouer le fil de la confiance mais il y
a urgence il tient à chacun de nous de
changer sa façon d'être et
d'écouter faites de vos différences une
richesse mais pas une force qui écrase
vous grandissez dans une société qui se
construit trop par le conflit la vie
n pas le Réau social l'anonym c'est le
mode d'expression des faibles des lâch
le désaccord pour le désaccord c'est la
défaite pour chacun je suis comme les
Français je crois Lass de voir les gens
se déchirer par principe plutôt que par
conviction il est là le risque de
basculement qui nous gu si N prenons pas
garde se mettre d'accord avec celui qui
ne vient pas du même endroit que vous
avecelui qui n pasé penser comme vous
pas la compromission non c'est du
courage politique cela s'appelle
d'ailleurs le dépassement cher au
président de la
République les enfants assumer expliquer
la complexité des choses de la vie les
décisions que vous aurez à prendre
rétrécir la parole aller toujours plus
vite simplifier la pensée c'est pas
faire confiance à l'autre c'est par
conséquent ne donner aucune chance à
l'autre de vous faire confiance en
retour c'est la parole qui est d'or le
silence lui et de plomb alors usez la
parole gardez toujours l'esprit alerte
acceptez de reconnaître que vous pouvez
avoir tort d'ailleurs on peut avoir
raison sur le fond mais jamais lorsqu'on
a raison seul on ne sort pas gagnant
d'un conflit parce qu'on l' gagné par
autorité 1000 chemins peuvent conduire à
un même
résultat trouvez au fond de vous ce qui
vous indigne vous motive ce qui vous
fait rêver vous mobilise ne le gardez
pas pour vous portez-le à travers toute
forme d'engagement si si je n'ai conu
plus grand honneur que de pouvoir servir
mon pays à la santé au Parlement à la
démocratie il y a 1000 autres façons de
s'engager et la voix que j'ai choisi
n'est ni plus prestigieuse ni plus
efficace qu'une autre je pense à ces
jeunes pendant le covid qui se sont
mobilisés c'était le confinement pour
servir des repas aux personnes âgées
isolées je pense à ces premières lignes
invisible dans la cité qui ont à elles
seul permis à notre pays de tenir debout
je pense à ces millions de Français qui
se retrouvent dans des gymnases dans des
salle communale le soir venu pour
partager leur passion pour la culture le
sport le jeu la danse
et surtout les enfants soyez
heureux faites du sport faites-vous des
amis cultivez-vous lisez levez le nez de
vos écrans il nous prennent à tous
beaucoup trop de temps et d'énergie
apprenez à faire confiance apprenez à
aimer apprenez à vous appuyer sur les
autres autant qu'à leur servir d'appui
vous êtes l'avenir de notre démocratie
comme tous les enfants de ce pays où
qu'il soi né ou qu'il grandissent qu que
soi les chances qui leur été donné par
la naissance par l'éducation qu'ils ont
reçu fils de ton fils ou fils d'étranger
tous les enfants sont des sorciers c'est
ce que chantait Jacques Brell que
j'écouter en boucle quand j'avais votre
âge j'en ai fini avec cet aparté publ
chapriska je vais désormais te céder la
magnifique mission que j'ai eu tant de
bonheur à occuper je voudrais avant cela
avoir un mot pour les équipes avec
lesquelles j'ai eu l'immense honneur de
travailler toutes ces années les
Français ne connaissent ni leur nom ni
leur visage ils sont conseillers ils
sont secrétaires agents de sécurité
conducteurs cuisin
mais sans eux sans le sens de
l'engagement qu'il ment à travailler je
le dis à des heures indues aucun d'entre
nous ne réussirait dans ses missions
auprès d'eux j'ai appris la fidélité la
loyauté la confiance le
respect après avoir porté la parole du
gouvernement je retrouve donc désormais
une pleine liberté de parole j'en userai
fidèle à mes convictions socialdémocrate
humaniste européenne résolument
progressiste je redeviens dans quelques
semaine député de ma magnifique
circonscription urbaine et montagneuse
de Grenoble et de la proche vallée du
grésigodan j'aime la politique comme les
marins sont appelés par les
M j'aime l'action publique comme j'ai
chéri la médecine j'aime la France ce
petit cœur battant du monde et
par-dessus tout j'aime les Français de
Damarie léiss à Gradignan d'aubervillier
à eninbaaumont de Dijon à Créteil en
passant bien sûr par Grenoble nos
échanges seront désormais ma boussol et
oui j'aime tous les Français même ceux
qui conteste même ceux qui rallochent
même ceux qui ne sont jamais contents
parce qu'il nous poussent à aller plus
loin et que j'ai hâte d'aller plus loin
à leur côté avec un cap qui qui ne
cessera jamais de me guider continuer à
affronter le populisme l'extrême droite
qui sont un poison pour notre pays et
notre démocratie et je le ferai sans
relâche vous pouvez compter sur moi je
vous remercie et je vous dis à
bientôt
monsieur monsieur le ministre délégué
très cher Olivier Mesdames et Messieurs
chers amis maman c'est un honneur un
véritable honneur de te succéder toi
l'homme de parole et ce ne sont pas ces
lieux qui vont m contredire mais toi
aussi et surtout l'homme d'action et
j'insiste sur ce mot car oui Olivier tu
as été et tu resteras le ministre de la
Santé qui a su au pire de la crise
relever tes manches ne pas douter ne pas
sourciller et protéger les Françaises et
les Français au cœur d'une crise que
tous penser insurmontable ce n'était pas
compté ce n'est pas sans compter sur ta
détermination et ton
engagement puis en tant que porte-parole
tu as su nous parler leur parler en
conjuguant transparence pédagogie et
opinreeté pour tout cela
Olivier merci merci
infiniment c'est aujourd'hui avec
honneur et aussi avec un sentiment de
fierté et de responsabilité que j'ai
accepté la mission qui m'a été confiée
par le Président de la République sur
proposition du Premier ministre cette
mission qui me permet à mon tour de
porter aujourd'hui la parole de ce
nouveau gouvernement de porter la parole
d'une équipe d'un collectif d'un
collectif sous l'autorité de Gabriel
Atal avec en charge de traduire en acte
les engagements pris par le Président de
la République car oui il s'agit bien
d'un collectif fait d'hommes et de
femmes qui n'ont qu'une seule boussole
agir agir et servir les Françaises et
les Français ce rôle je l'endosse avec
humilité et responsabilité car je sais
au combien les attentes sont nombreuses
depuis 2017 le gouvernement et la
majorité présidentielle n'ont eu de
cesse de réformer notre pays dans tous
les domaines pour qu'il demeure une
nation forte et solidaire une nation qui
est Fiè d'elle et qui peut ainsi
rayonner au-delà de ces
frontières ce que je souhaite incarner
avec vous c'est cette volonté ardente de
faire de notre France pluriel une
République unie au moment des ruptures
des nonit des silences ce ministère doit
être
inlassablement celui du dialogue entre
le gouvernement et les journalistes bien
sûr dont l'indépendance dont votre
indépendance et votre liberté constitue
des des valeurs sacrées au sein de notre
République dans un monde où celles-ci
sont tant attaquées de toutes parts un
dialogue aussi et surtout entre le
gouvernement et les Français je veux que
ce ministère soit celui de l'ouverture
et de la maintendue l'action public les
mesures engagées par l'ensemble de mes
collègues sur la responsabilité du
Président de la République et du Premier
ministre doivent être nourit d'un
dialogue permanent avec vous ce dialogue
me permettra d'incarner le récit de
chacun dans chaque territoire en
hexagone comme en outreem ce dialogue me
permettra enfin d'être une porte-parole
d'action d'être la couroie de
transmission entre les mots et les actes
je ferai de ce ministère dans ta
continuité Olivier celui des échanges
sincères libres et clair c'est également
basket au pied comme on l'a souvent été
ensemble sur le terrain que je suis
convaincu que que nous pourrons faire
ensemble toute la différence parce que
le gouvernement et la majorité
présidentielle s'y attachent depuis 2017
et c'est bien avec les Français qu'on
construit notre pays non pas à côté ni
face à face c'est la rencontre qui fait
la politique et pas l'inverse c'est ce
renouveau démocratique que je veux
porter dans la droite ligne de ce que tu
as actionné Olivier et qui s'inscrira
dans une volonté d'action sur des
chemins peut-être un peu tradition
car oui à l'URE des réseaux sociaux et
du tout numérique retrouvons le plaisir
de nous adosser ensemble à des bistr
pour échanger en se regardant droit dans
les yeux et aussi évidemment avec une
pensée particulière que je prends
aujourd'hui ses fonctions une pensée
particulière pour la jeunesse notre
jeunesse car oui au cours de ces 6
derniers mois secrétaire d'État à la
Jeunesse et auosnu au côté de Gabriel
j'ai consacré toute mon énergie à aller
partout sur les territoires à la
rencontre de nos jeunes à qui certains
promettent des murs là où nous
souhaitons offrir des ponts j'ai
consacré toute mon énergie à défaire les
récits pessimistes qui ne les autorisent
plus à croire en l'avenir j'ai consacré
toute mon énergie à leur expliquer qu'il
existe des mouvements positifs des
perspectives excitantes et des scénarios
alternatifs au déterministes c'est mêmes
scénario que nous porterons nous aussi
également en tant que parents auprès de
nos
enfants à T que j'ai rencontré et à
toutes celles et ceux que je
continuerons que je continuerai à
rencontrer pardon j'aimerais leur dire
ou peut-être leur redire ce que mon père
me disait alors que j'étais
petite si tout peut paraître difficile
rien n'est jamais
impossible déjouer les pronostics
renverser les préjugés susp surpendre et
se laisser surend surprendre c'est le
premier message que je tiens à adresser
à nos concitoyens en tant que
porte-parole en quelques mots vous
l'aurez compris je serai donc la
porte-parole de ce gouvernement mais
votre porte-parole alors mesdames et
messieurs ce ministère sera celui du
dialogue et de l'optimisme assumons-le
fièrement en d'autres termes il sera
celui de la République de notre
République fière fière de ce qu'elle est
de ce qu'elle apporte et de ce qu'elle
est capable de faire je vous remercie et
je vous dis à très vite sur nos
territoires mais attention mon dernier
mot reviendra à William Samira ché
Antoine Maxime au boulot
[Applaudissements]
maintenant la maman
merci
beaucoup
9h20 nous sommes en direct bonjour
bienvenue nouvelle journée très
politique au Figaro et partout en France
surtout dans les ministères les
passations de pouvoir ont débuté vous
venez de voir celle du porte-parole un
porte-parole qui se transforme en une
porte-parole Olivier verrant quitte le
ministère et laisse sa place à priscat
TNO Emmanuel galero bonjour bonjour
bonjour du service politique on va
parler évidemment de Rashid adati parce
que c'est la grande passation de pouvoir
que tout le monde attend ce matin et un
mot quand même rapidement sur sur ce
qu'on vient de voir Olivier verérrand
quitte le gouvernement le porte-parole
et puis surtout le gouvernement ça
faisait longtemps qu'il y était Olivier
verrand oui oui alors visiblement en
coulisse ce qui se trame c'est que on
pense à lui pour les européennes oui
donc il y a aussi cette carte-là et
c'est d'ailleurs euh je pense une des
des clés de lecture de de ce de ce
remanement et notamment concernant
Rachid adati il faut se souvenir que
Rachid adati en 2009 avait été candidate
avec Michel Barnier aux européennes sous
les les couleurs de l'UMP d'accord et à
cette époque le le parti avait obtenu
29,6 % des voix de mémoire c'est donc
aussi pour la macronie une manière de de
de de jouer cette carte là et de
déstabiliser aussi la droite tenez
regardez les premières images qui nous
arrivent du ministère de la Culture on a
encore ce cinté porte-parole priscat
remplace Olivier Verron parce que c'est
ce que nous venons de vivre ensemble ça
a été assez court une vingtaine de
minutes même pas un petit quart d'heure
pour cette passation entre Olivier
verrant et priscat evno Olivier verrant
qui a parlé de ses enfants longuement
priscat evno qui a salué son travail
notamment au ministère de la santé avant
même d'être d'être porte-parole mais
donc Olivier verérant quitte le le
gouvernement et on s'intéresse donc à ce
qui va se passer dans un instant au au
ministère de la Culture Emmanuel
ça'était une grosse surprise on l'a pas
du tout vu venir je sais pas vous au
service politique mais alors nous on est
tombé des nuus person alors personne ne
l'a vu venir et encore moins ce qui est
le plus troublant c'est chez LR les
républicains ne s'y attendaient pas du
tout et même quelques minutes avant
d'ailleurs nous-même nous l'avons révélé
annoncé à de nombreux élus des
républicains qui étit vraiment sceptique
et qu' n'y croyaient pas ah oui
absolument ils n'y croyaient pas et ils
y croyaient d'ailleurs d'autant moins
euh que
en discutant avec Eric chotti notamment
président des républicains il avait eu
un échange avec Gabriel Atal dès mardis
téléphonique dans lequel le le nouveau
Premier ministre s'engageait
personnellement à ne pas réaliser de
débauchages vous savez les débauchages
ah oui oui il s'est arrangé
en fait c'est il avait annoncé les
choses comme ça en disant en précisant
d'ailleurs que c'était son choix qu' ne
préférait pas faire de débauchage et il
avait dit la même chose d'ailleurs à
Olivier marlex président euh du groupe
LR à l'Assemblée euh en lui assurant que
c'était pas son intention et en ajoutant
quand même une petite précision en
expliquant que c'était peut-être qu' ne
savait pas ce qui allait se passer du
côté de l'Élysée bon alors aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce qui se passe la droite
découvre découvre ce ce ralliment on
sait pas si c'est un
débuchageti a prévenu ericotti peu de
temps avant temps ça fait hier soir en
réité oui parce que l'annonce a été
faite à 19h40 par Monsieur coller le
secrétaire génal de l'Élysée depuis
l'Élysée et on a commencé à prendre la
rumeur vers 17h30 18h éricti n'était pas
au courant jusqu'à dans l'après-midi euh
il dès qu'il l'a su il a cherché à la
contacter ils ont eu un échange
euh elle lui a annoncé son intention
donc de rejoindre lui expliquant qu'en
réalité elle avait eu rendez-vous le
matin même avec Emmanuel Macron qui lui
aurittin qui lui aurait dit qui lui
aurait dit on attend attendait plus que
toi pour boucler ce gouvernementend plus
to ça ce sont les explications de Rachid
hadtiord fait à ericioti et donc elle
annonce
cette ce ce transfert on va dire en
expliquant qu'évidemment elle quitte les
républicains de faitti prend acte de ce
départ d'accord ou elle elle a pas
essayer de garder sa place au sein des
républicains Rach par parce que ça était
l'une des premières questions qu'on
qu'on s'est posé est-ce un grand euh une
grande coalition enfin le grand
rassemblement voulu par Nicolas Sarkozi
entre les macronistes et la droite le
suspense a vite été levéti a tout de
suite annoncé qu'il qu'il ne voulait
plus voir achti au sein des LR non non
il a pris acte de cette décision avec
les en exprimant les regrets évidemment
des républicains euh et c'est un peu un
coup dur pour lui c'est une forme je
pense qu'il le vit comme une comme quand
même une trahison puisque Eric choti
avait travaillé étroitement avec Rachid
il lui avait confié le le la présidence
du Conseil national des républicains ce
qui est quand même un poste important
chez LR il l'IT fait en confiance et
d'ailleurs rien ne laissait penser en
tout cas sur les plateaux télé et la
manière dont dont rachidati défendait la
droite et parfois critiquait même la
macronie rien ne pouvait laisser penser
que qu'elle qu'elle accepterait ce choix
mais elle avait aussi des liens Rachid
hadti des liens privilégiés avec
Emmanuel Macron avec Brigitte Macron
alors c'est vrai tout ça parce que j'ai
entendu hier soir Guillaume Tabar est
venu sur le plateau au moment de la
passation nous a dit qu'il avait des
liens qu'elle avait des liens avec
Emmanuel Macron et puis on nous a dit
aussi Guillaume roquet et Carl juste
avant qu'elle avait des liens avec
Gabriel Atal qu'elle croisait rue de
Grenel parce que les ministères et le
ministère du porte-parole et la mairie
du 7e arrondissement sont face à faceace
elle a des liens avec tout le monde non
mais c'est le microcosme politique
parisienne tout le monde se connaît tout
le monde se tutoie tout le monde
s'apprécie et après il y a des lignes
politiques qui divergent bon c'est
souvent comme ça et Rachid adti c'est
vrai qu'elle avait des proximités avec
la avec Emmanuel Macron mais et aussi
alors surtout ce qu'il faut comprendre
c'est que Rachid adati c'est une des
premières des plus fidèles sarkoistes et
et avec niikola Sarkozi elle partagit
cette analyse selon laquelle il faudrait
que les républicains et la droite
pensent à un accord de gouvernement avec
euh avec le le le le le pouvoir oui
cette ligne là c'est on ex ex au cœur du
sujet c'estàd que c'est une ligne qui a
été actée avec l'élection d'Eric cotti à
la présidence des républicains je vous
rappelle que il a gagné cette élection
mais il y avait également en deuxème
position Bruno retaillot qui était lui
aussi sur une ligne de rupture franche
et pas du tout sur cette possibilité de
se raller ou de de s'allier avec le
pouvoir et depuis on a vu au fil des
débats parlementaires que c'était pas du
tout le choix le choix de la droite mais
par contre cette cette ce message là cet
appel à un
rassemblement au nom de la France
d'ailleurs son son est avancé souvent
sous cette formme là le cet argument on
l'a vu hier soir d'ailleurs Renaud
Muselier qui n'est plus LR a tout de
suite lancé un tweet vous avez
vu un twet un peu ironique d'ailleurs
disant il y aura peut-être de mémoire je
crois qu' il dit a il y aura il y aura
bientôt plus de cadres LR au
gouvernement que au sein des
républicains donc c'est très méchant
très intéressant parce que LR qui était
le grand parti de gouvernement de la
droite de la 5e République l'UMP le RPR
et cetera aujourd'hui les cadres s'en
vont parce que on peut la faire la liste
he depuis 7 ans Bruno Le Maire Gérald
armanin qui était déjà des pointures à
l'époque puis même Édouard Philippe bon
même sitait pas forcément très connu il
eu ensuite Damien Abad qui était quand
même le président deslr à l'Assemblée
puis rachidti désormais et on n'oublie
pas éic Christian estri et Renault
Muselier dans le sud il y en a plus
beaucoup des cadres cette question alors
cette question elle est centrale
évidemment à droite et ça sera une
question à laquelle ericti devra
répondre aussi dès mardi hein sur un
conseil
stratégique et bon beaucoup de il a
beaucoup de colère à droite aujourd'hui
hein ah ils sont en colère oui il y a
beaucoup de colère parce que cette
droite là qui a beaucoup souffert on se
souvient de la présidentielle avec
l'échec de Valley pcrè euh il y a les
européennes qui profil et la la droite
essaie de se reconstruire depuis et elle
se reconstruit avec un un socle assez
faible aujourd'hui ils sont 61 députés
euh ce qui est pas assez peu mais qui
pèse mais qui pèse évidemment parce
qu'ils sont ils sont ils ont un rôle
quand même centrale au Parlement et ils
ont une majorité aussi au Sénat mais la
difficulté c'est que cette fragilité
politique elle on a aujourd'hui des élus
qui ont résisté donc au macronisme et on
voit bien que depuis depuis 2017
Emmanuel Macron visiblement ça se
confirme avec ce dernier débauchage de
Rachid hadti n'a qu'une seule ambition
finalement c'est de d'affaiblir la
droite et il ne lâche pas cet objectif
oui après avoir largement affaibli la
gauche lors du premier quinquena
l'entreprise de destruction de la droite
qui a commencé il y a 3 3 4 ans est en
train de se poursuivre il le fait
mécaniquement presque méthodiquement et
on pensait et la droite penser que avec
les dernières déclarations de Gabriel
hatal annonçant euh qui voulait écouter
toutes les oppositions et construire
enfin les messages positifs de son de de
juste avant son sa nomination ben font
que aujourd'hui ils étaient plutôt
optimistes sauf que
patatra rachelti
entre au gouvernement
9h29 la passation de pouvoir entre Rima
abdoumak ministre de la Culture sortante
et Rachid Dati ministre de la Culture en
30 surprise doit commencer il est 9h30
ça y est il y a un peu de retard
visiblement les photographes sont prêts
on va suivre attentivement ce qui se dit
alors manuel
yaliero ce qui peut surprendre les
Français je ne suis pas certain qu'ils
aiment beaucoup c'est trahison mais ils
peuvent le comprendre s'il y a un vrai
lien voyez on va chercher un ministre
important à droite parce que il a une
vraie connaissance en santé alors on le
met au ministère de la santé c'est un
économiste de renom alors on va le
chercher Rachid à la culture
alors c'est une question qu'on peut se
poser effectivement mais là où qu'
l'autre lecture qu'on peut avoir de
cette nomination c'est aussi dans la
perspective des prochaines municipales
oui vous savez que Rachid oui mais alors
là c'est là où vous me parlez de
politique politicienne et les acteurs du
monde de la culture ont envie d'avoir un
ministre qui connaît leur domaine les
Français on envie d'avoir un ministre
qui connaît son domaine là vous me
parlez de politique de d'ambition voilà
c'est là où on a du mal à comprendre ah
là vous voyez bien que ce ce ce
gouvernement resserré pose aussi des
questions dans le sens où sur
l'éducation on attendait c'est un
ministre plein et il se trouve que c'est
pas c'est pas le choix qui a été fait
donc on peut pas évidemment que il y a
dans ce dans ce gouvernement euh des
messages politiques une ambition très
politicienne
de de d'affaiblir évidemment la droite
et et de d'essayer de de de de poser de
faire de donner l'illusion en fait d'un
nouveau départ alors qu'on est vraiment
dans la continuité même si évidemment ce
gouvernement est renforcé sur sa droite
mais la lecture c'est c'est aussi celle
de des prochaines municipales vous savez
que rachidti c'est aussi je pense
qu'elle a accepter aussi ce ce cet
accord et d'entrer dans ce gouvernement
c'est c'est aussi dans la perspective de
ces élections elle ne pourrait pas
gagner par alors expliquez-nous
expliquez-nous Rachid alti on le sait
rêve de devenir maire de Paris elle en a
fait son ambition depuis quelques années
couleurs de la droite qui la soutient a
d'ailleurs organisé les dernières
sénatoriales à Paris euh un peu dans ce
sens-là hein pour essayer de consolider
ceses ces alliances elle est présidente
du groupe changer Paris au sein du
Conseil de Paris alors attendez je vous
montre une image quand même on change un
peu de ministère c'est l'arrivée de
Stéphane séjourné qui va remplacer
Catherine Colona on a vu furtivement
l'image on les entendra juste après
Emmanuel et puis on repasse pardon je
vous coupe mais c'est aussi l'actualité
ce matin ces différentes passations de
pouvoir
euh avec donc là le ministère des
Affaires étrangères qui va être un peu
éclipsé parce que la passation de
pouvoir a lieu au même moment que celle
de l'éducation nationale entre Gabriel
Atal le nouveau Premier ministre et
Amélie oua casterra pas sûr qu'on voit
beaucoup d'images en direct ce matin je
repasse sur le ministère de la Culture
et je vous laisse poursuivre oui donc
sur cette les municipales c'est vraiment
très important de de de voir aussi cette
cette nomination dans ce sens-là puisque
Rachid hadti si elle veut espérer
gagner les municipales à Paris il lui
faudra il lu faudrait elle sera encore
plus forte avec des alliances et un
soutien macroniste alors reste la
question c'est la question reste posé
hein c'est qu'elle est présidente quand
même du groupe changer Paris oui qui est
le principal opposant
àidalgo elle ne peut pas rester maire du
7e arrondissement alors je pense ça va
pas être possible elle va elle va
déléguer son poste mais elle peut rester
élu peut rester élu oui et donc elle va
continuer son projet sans lâcher je
pense pour les municipales je sais pas
comment ça va s'organiser euh mais euh
la question pour qu' va se poser à
droite c'est comment faire est-ce que
ils vont se choisir un nouveau candidat
pour de 2026 les élections mars et juin
2026 ça aussi c'est une question qui
sera posée sur la table de la droite
est-ce que la droite peut continuer à
soutenir Rachid adati est-ce que ça peut
être une candidate même si elle n'est
plus au sein des républicains euh
qu'est-ce qui va se passer moi je je
pense que sur des élections locales la
personnalité compte parfois plus que
l'étiquette politique et le grand
mouvement national qui est entraîné en
fonction des des partis hein parce que
l'autre problème de de de de la droite
aussi c'est que ils ont un un déficit de
de de de de visage et notamment de
visage féminin on l'a vu d'ailleurs aux
européennes ils sont en train de
chercher euh il ils ont fait la Parbelle
un visage féminin à la présidentielle on
a vu comment ça s'est passé avec Valéri
pcrè donc oui alors pour des raisons on
va pour en parler encore oui
mais c'est vrai que les deux grands
visages féminins de la droite jusquici
c'était rachidti et Valérie PC l'une est
très clairement discrédité après son
échec à la présidentielle l'autre vient
de quitter le parti voilà donc il y a
pas il y a pas vraiment c'est vrai que
c'est il y a une peu un peu une pénurie
de ce côté-là et et c'est pour ça que
c'est aussi un coup politique pour pour
les macronistes de d'arriver à à à
débaucher la
dernière la
dernière incarnation de cette droite et
qui d'ailleurs faisait le
jobach aussi un bon soldat c'est quand
il s'agit de défendre sur les plateaux
droite elle l'a fait
brillamment en
attaquant en
attaquant directement la macronie il est
9h35 nous sommes en direct nous
attendons l'arrivée de rachidti à ce
pupitre elle parlera après Rima Abdou
Malak il y a un vrai
changement de personnalité et à la tête
de ce ministère ça nous fait presque
penser à la nomination de PAP juste
après Jean-Michel blanc au ministère de
l'Éducation là on change complètement de
bord R abdoum qui
était l'une des têtes de la majorité de
gauche disons d'Emmanuel Macron
contrairement à rachidti qui elle n'est
même pas dans la majorité de droite et
qui va de fait la rejoindre mais qui est
très clairement à droite oui alors sans
doute que Rima Abd Malak paye aussi la
dégradation de ses relations avec
Emmanuel
Macron et donc le poste était vacant
alors pour Rachid hadti la culture c'est
aussi un sans doute aussi un défi he
puis elle a un tempérament qui on on va
voir je sais pas quelles sont les
réactions globales dans le monde de la
culture il y a beaucoup de scepticisme
sans doute mais peut-être que aussi dans
la lecture
des le ministre de la Culture à Paris
c'est quand même pas rien non plus hein
vis-à-vis d' dalgo on peut imaginer
qu'il y aura des des batailles oui parce
qu'elle a son mot à dire sur plusieurs
chantiers par exemple on pense à au
parvis de NotreDame me semble-t-il qui
est un une discussion entre la mairie de
Paris et le ministère de la Culture sur
son réaménagement ça peut être un levier
pour la la candidate au municipal Rachid
c'est ça qui me fascine Emmanuel c'est
bon j'entends mais vous on voit dans ce
que vous nous dites ce matin que ce
n'est qu'un marche-pied et que Rachid
adati pense avant tout à la mairie de
Paris j'imagine qu'elle va tenter là
dans le discours qu'elle prononcera dans
quelques minutes on imagine dans
quelques secondes
de nous prouver que la culture elle y
tient queelle est très attachée au poste
et que ce n'est pas que pour devenir
mère de Paris qu'elle a accepté de
rentrer dans le gouvernement de Gabriel
évidemment mais personne ne sera dupe et
c'est vrai que certains élus soulignent
ce problème là notamment on en a un à
droite qui sera candidat aux européennes
pour les républicains c'est frz André
manouquant qui est donc là lors de cette
passation de pouvoir entre Rima Abdul
mala qu'on vient de voir passer
rapidement et Rachid hadti a-t-il été
invité par l'une ou par l'autre
intéressant intéressant de le savoir oui
je disais juste que cette déception que
vous exprimez vous-même en disant on
comprend rien c'est la politique ça peut
pas être que de la queune approche
politicienne seulement et c'est c'est
d'ailleurs un désastre aujourd'hui on
voit bien l'impact que ça peut avoir
dans la dans la société sur l'opinion
les gens ne croient plus trop en la
politique en ni en ceux qui l'incarnent
pour ces raisons-là euh il y a a il y a
pas tellement de de raison de croire
quand on voit un peu c'est c'est c'est
c'est c'est ces manières de faire de la
politique avec ces intentions là de de
croire en en en l'ambition qui qui est
plutôt louable de de l'acteur politique
qui veut faire avancer son pays sur des
questions fondamentales là euh pour
l'instant on verra mais c'est on est on
est dans la dans dans dans d'abord la
stupéfaction à droite et puis après ça a
été le le le choc de de ne pas
comprendre quelles sont les ambitions
réelles qui sont derrière la Dati
sera-t-elle contrôlable on sait que
c'est une forte personnalité pardon
grande gueule euh qui sait faire de la
politique qui a un compte Twitter
d'ailleurs punchline Datti hein où on
l'entend
assainer leur cas de vérité à tous ses
opposants politiques est-ce qu'elle va
être contrôlable elle a du tempérament
euh elle a aussi euh une une affaire
judiciaire sur sur le dos et ah ça c'est
intéressant oui allez-y non je connais
pas le détail de cette cette affaire là
mais mise en examen dans l'affaire
carlosg voilà l'affaire Renault et bon
c'est histoire d'argent
elle s'en défend aussi fortement mais
tout c tout ça est en suspens et c'est
vrai que à droite elle avait une
position un peu particulière
c'est-à-dire que Rachid Dati on la
sentait pas forcément toujours en phase
avec la ligne mais étant incluse dans ce
parti et ayant obtenu le poste de de
président du conseil nationale elle
était obligée évidemment de tenir un
certain discours collant à la ligne LR
mais on la sentait pas honnêtement hein
en discutant avec elle au fil des des
des des des derniers mois on la sentait
toujours un peu en décalage elle avait
un son propre discours par exemple sur
l'immigration étant elle-même issue euh
de de l'immigration elle elle était
alors elle marchait un peu sur des œufs
mais elle avait une une ligne parfois un
peu elle voulait faire entendre sa ligne
c'est vrai qu'elle a quand même du
tempérament et qu'elle est respectée
aussi pour ça elle était respectée aussi
pour ça au sein des républicains parce
que quand elle a quelque chose à dire
elle le dit et et beaucoup la craignait
aussi aussi par ses relation avec
Nicolas Sarkozi qui sont très sa
proximité avec Sarkozi qui est très
forte je salue Charles qui nous dit
bonjour sur Youtube je lit ce que nous
dit Lucifer 34 c'est un pseudo qui fait
peur c'est un bon choix qu'il faut
soutenir voilà elle a l'air satisfaite
Lucifer de voir arriver Rachid adati
c'est surtout une personne différente
elle a ses objectifs politiques c'est
certain mais c'est un bon choix voilà ce
que pense l'une de nos inter alors on on
observe il y a des avis très très
différents mais il faut rappeler quand
même quelque chose c'est que on a bien
vu avec la la la présidentielle de
Valérie PCR il y a eu un problème
Sarkozi pcrè pendant la présidentielle
oui bien sûr Nicolas Sarkozi n'a pas
soutenu n'a jamais soutenu Valéri PCR il
n'a jamais soutenu Valé PCR il a pas
plus soutenu d'autres opérations
politiques de la droite depuis il avait
pris du recul en disant ça y est nous
attendons commence Abd et Rachid
arrivent ensemble et la ministre de la
Culture sortante prend la
parole s'il vous
plaît
madame la
ministre s'il vous
plaît madame la ministre chers Rachida
et chers
amis il y a 20 mois je me tenais ici à
ce même pupitre au côté de Roseline
Bachelot et dans mon discours de prise
de fonction
je disais que devenir ministre n'était
pas un rêve pour moi je disais mon rêve
c'était de devenir libre et de le
rester en acceptant cette magnifique
responsabilité que m'avait confié le
président de la République et la
première ministre ellisabeth borne je me
suis mise au service d'une ambition pour
la France à laquelle j'ai cru totalement
ardemment mais je suis restée libre
libre de mes engagements libre
de mes prises de
position libre dans mon amour pour les
artistes 20 mois c'est cours à l'échelle
de la riche histoire de ce ministère
mais mon dévouement à notre politique
culturelle sous l'égit d'Emmanuel Macron
avait commencé bien avant en novembre
2019 depuis l'Élysée j'étais dans
l'ombre mais déjà dans l'action en appui
à franester puis à Roseline
Bachelot ces années ont permis de
grandes avan
la création du Centre national de la
musique par exemple un soutien inégalé à
la culture pendant la crise sanitaire
l'année blanche pour les intermittents
devenus une année et demi un plan de
relance pour toutes les filières
culturelles près de 260 projets
artistique réalisé dans le cadre du
programme monde nouveau partout sur le
territoire des nominations féminisées
diversifiées à la tête de nos
institutions un passeculture transformé
amplifié des efforts inédits aussi pour
la lecture érigée grande cause
nationale depuis mai 2022 j'ai été
extrêmement heureuse à la tête de ce
ministère chaque journée avait son lot
de problème à résoudre évidemment et de
bataille à mener mais chaque journée a
eu ces moments éblouissants et
transformateurs notamment lors de mes
multiples déplacement sur le terrain à
la rencontre des forces vives de la
culture des élus des associations
mes boussoles ici ont toujours été clair
développer l'appétit de culture de notre
jeunesse défendre la souveraineté
culturelle de la France face à
l'hégémonie des plateformes numériques
préserver et transmettre notre
patrimoine apaiser les mémoires par la
culture défendre l'audiovisuel public et
lutter contre la
désinformation agir enfin pour la
transition
écologique à chaque déplacement
international j'ai pu constater à quel
point ces enjeux raisonnaient fortement
à l'étranger à quel point la France
était montrer en exemple et les
mutations de notre modèle culturel
scruté avec attention ces grandes
priorités je les ai porté avec une
équipe à l'énergie incroyable
visionnaire passionné qui ne comptait
jamais ses heures une équipe héroïque je
tiens à les remercier très sincèrement
ainsi que notre comité de direction si
soudé si si talentueux remercier bien
sûr nos directeurs régionaux des
Affaires Culturelles les dirigeants de
nos quelques 80 établissements et
opérateurs et l'ensemble des agents du
ministère j'ai pu mesurer au quotidien
la force de leur engagement la qualité
de leur expertise et leur sens du
service
public je suis Fiè de tout ce que nous
avons pu accomplir ensemble achev par
exemple des chantiers majeurs comme
celui de la BNF Richelieu après 12 ans
de travaux tout de même ou celui de la
transformation du château de
villeercotteray en Cité internationale
de la langue
française passer deux lois historiques
pour faciliter les restitutions des
biens spoliés aux familles juives et
celles des restes humains appartenants à
nos collections réussir à mettre à
contribution les plateformes de
streaming pour participer au financement
de la filière musicale étendre le passe
culture dans sa version collective aux
élèves de 6e et de 5e ou encore
redoubler d'efforts pour nos écoles
d'architecture qui sont de véritables
pépites pour l'avenir ces réalisations
elles ne sont pas éphémères elles sont
structurantes elles sont
durables je suis fière d'avoir obtenu
les budgets les plus élevés de
l'histoire de ce ministère en hausse de
7 % en 2023 et à nouveau de 6 % pour
2024 avec la création de 125 emplois
supplémentaires et la sauvegarde de
nombreux crédits d'impôt qui sont
indispensable à la vitalité du secteur
de la
culture après la suppression de la
redevance je me suis battu bec et ongles
pour sécuriser le financement de
l'audisuelle public et négocier une
trajectoire budgétaire en hausse donnant
une visibilité aux entreprises jusqu'à
2028 et fixant le cap de plusieurs
transformations tu avais raison cher
Rachida quand tu disais l'an dernier que
l'audiovisuel public fait partie du
parcours républicain et de l'égalité des
chances à l'heure où notre société est
bousculée par la désinformation par une
défiance croissante des Français
vis-à-vis des médias par je dirais une
simplification trop fréquente de la
pensée les entreprises de l'audiovisuel
public dont les équipes travaillent avec
rigueur et en toute indépendance ont un
rôle crucial à jouer pour préserver
notre
démocratie quand j'ai été nommé ministre
je n'avais jamais fait d'interview dans
les médias je n'avais jamais été au banc
à l'Assemblée et j'avais ma carte dans
aucun parti on me disait novis en
politique mais la politique a toujours
été lié à ma vie parce que tout est
politique tenter de comprendre une
guerre civile qui déchire son pays quand
on est enfant c'est
politique habiter une autre langue que
sa langue maternelle l'aimer la la
défendre grandir avec elle ses
politiques organiser des spectacles dans
des camps de réfugés ou des bidonville
avec les clownes Sans Frontière c'est
politique le rire lui-même est politique
le rire est subversif le rire est
résistance servir pendant 6 ans
l'ambition culturelle de Bertrand de
laané mon mentor absolu c'est
politique promouvoir la culture
française à New York n'est-ce pas aussi
politique défendre les droits des femmes
la lutte contre le harcèlement et les
violences sexuelles et sexistes
aussi soutenir la culture arménienne
ou accueillir des artistes exilés d'Iran
d'Ukraine ou d'Afghanistan c'est là
encore politique c'est même
civilisationnel bref je n'ai pas compris
pourquoi on me collait si souvent
l'étiquette de techno moi qui n'ai
jamais passé un seul concours
administratif de ma vie et qui n'ai
jamais travaillé dans la haute fonction
publique
en tout cas le président m'a fait
confiance la première ministre aussi et
je ne les en remercierai jamais assez je
me suis jeté corps et âmees dans cette
fonction en me disant qu'il était
possible d'être une femme politique
autrement avec toutes mes
différences je veux d'ailleurs remercier
ici les parlementaires avec qui j'ai
travaillé tout au long de ces 20 mois et
précédemment quand j'étais culture à
l'Élysée c'était un bonheur d'échanger
avec vous de vivre la réalité de vos
circonscriptions et de faire évoluer nos
travaux en en tenant compte de vos
avis je dois vous faire un aveu
j'espèrait parvenir à déjouer la
malédiction qui s'est abatue sur le
ministère de la Culture depuis plus de
10 ans qui fait que les ministres
restent moins de 2 ans à leur
poste mais cette malédiction est
décidément tenace
j'ai plusieurs regrets en vous quittant
je regrette de ne pas voir les 101
visages de la relève ce programme que
j'ai imaginé pour élargir et diversifier
le vivier des nominations dans la
culture on était à la dernière phase de
sélection de ne pas pouvoir déployer
encore davantage le plan pour les
métiers d'art que j'ai porté avec Olivia
Grégoire de ne pas défendre la troè loi
cadre sur les restitutions des biens
culturels usurpés où mener les combats
européens pour la protection du droit
d'auteur et la liberté de la presse qui
venait tout juste de
commencer j'aurais aussi aimé poursuivre
le travail sur des projets qui me
tiennent à cœur la Maison du dessin de
presse l'Institut de la France et de
l'Algérie la maison des mondes africains
tous trois annoncés par le Président de
la République tous trois nous reliant à
notre histoire et à une part de notre
humanité j'avais aussi de magnifiques
poètes à vous faire découvrir dans mon
tout jeune Rima poésie club et
figurez-vous j'avais déjà écrit un texte
en
alexandrin pour répondre à une
éventuelle interpellation à la prochaine
cérémonie des Molières ou des
césares plus sérieusement dans le
domaine du patrimoine je sais chère
Rachida que tu vas veiller au destin du
pavillon des sources de Marie
cure et je ne doute pas que tu aideras à
faire émerger le meilleur projet pour la
reconversion de l'abaye de clair ou pour
les si vitraux contemporains de la
cathédrale Notre-Dame de
Paris je ne sais pas quel nouveau chemin
m'attendent à la sortie de la rue de
Valois mais je sais qu'ils seront beaux
et fraternels combatifs aussi parce que
je n'oublie pas le fil rouge de mes
engagements la défense de la liberté de
création d'une culture ouverte et
vivante qui accueille la diversité comme
une chance pour notre pays la lutte
contre l'extrême droite ces
manipulations ces
stigmatisations j'arrive à la conclusion
de mon discours mais je ne peux pas vous
quitter sans vous lire l'un de mes
poèmes préférés un poème d'André Shedid
une femme qui m'a énormément inspiré son
parcours à lui seul dit tout de la force
de la
culture sachant qu'elle nous sera ôtée
je m'émerveille de croire en notre
saison et que nos cœurs chaque fois
refusent l'ultime
nafrage que demain puisse compter quand
tout est abandon que nous soyons
ensemble égaré et lucide ardent et
quotidien et que l'amour demeure après
le
discrédit je m'émerveille du rêve qui
sond de l'avenir des soifs que rien ne
désaltère que nous soyons chasseurs et
gibiers à la fois gladiateur d'infini et
captif d'un mirage
l'aidé étant formel et la mort
souveraine je m' merveille de croire en
notre saison
merci
madame la
ministre madame la ministre cher
R
mesdames et
messieurs André merau le fondateur de ce
ministère avait une brillante
formule le ministre de la Culture a pour
mission de rendre accessible au plus
grand nombre les œuvres capitales de
l'humanité et d'abord la
France c'est dans cette belle tradition
que je m'inscris en arrivant rue de Valo
Mo où je suis à la fois très fier très
fier mais aussi très ému d'avoir été
nommé par le Président de la République
sur proposition du Premier
ministre rendre accessible au plus grand
nombre les œuvres de nos
écrivains de nos artistes de nos acteurs
c'est en effet un impressionnant
projet alors permettez-moi de dire que
je sais
personnellement c'est d'ailleurs pour ça
que ça
surprend permettez-moi de dire que je
sais personnellement ce que je dois à la
culture
française et vous l'avez dit Madame la
Ministre
cherima et nous avons cela en
commun une liberté de
penser notamment pour les femmes une
liberté de parler notamment pour les
femmes
une liberté de créer notamment pour les
femmes et une liberté de diffuser aussi
pour les
femmes je veux saluer ici tous mes
prédécesseurs qui ont travaillé ici et
en
particulier c'est vrai que j'ai une
attention particulière pour vous cher
Rima abdoumak je veux vous remercier
pour votre
action pour votre
disponibilité et je sais que je pourrais
compter sur vous dans les jours à
venir pour votre courage pour votre
travail vous l'avez rappelé nous avons
en commun d'incarner la diversité
culturelle qui fait la richesse de notre
société nous savons l'importance d'avoir
une culture en partage pour se sentir
pleinement appartenir à un pays grâce à
elle grâce à tous nos prédécesseurs la
5e République a permis qu'en
France la culture ne soit pas un bien
comme un
are c'est ce que nous appelons
l'exception
culturelle alors chacun sais que j'aime
me battre n'ayez pas
peur je serai donc toujours là pour
défendre cette exception
culturelle je vais maintenant mon tour
prendre ma part dans cette histoire élut
de Paris je sais combien la capitale est
riche en offre culturelle je vaaiain en
m'intéressant de près et vous l'avez
rappelé à son patrimoine et en
particulier à une réalisation
formidable qui est un défi mais qui est
un moment aussi historique celui
qu'avait lancé le président de la
République en 2019 la réouverture de
notreddame cette
année mais je veux rendre la culture
encore plus présente dans toutes les
villes toutes les régions dans tous les
territoires et vous en avez parlé il
nous faut bâtir une nouvelle culture
populaire pour tous c'est pas un mot ce
ne sont pas que des mots des quartiers à
la
ruralité cela ne peut se faire qu'en
liaision étroite avec les collectivités
territorial de métropole et
d'outrem ils pourront compter sur moi
pour les soutenir à
fond j'irai les rencontrer sur le
terrain nous aurons avec l'accueil du
Sommet de la Francophonie à villeercot
l'occasion de rappeler l'importance de
notre langue de son exceptionnel
rayonnement dans le monde elle est un
patrimoine que nous avons en
partage et nous l'avons en partage avec
des peuples des nations sur tous les
continents lors de ses vœux pour 2024 le
président de la République a parlé du R
moment de la
France dans ce
réarmement la culture a une place
essentielle les industries culturelles
les industries Créativ les nouvelles
technologies l'éducation artistique et
culturelle il est important la culture
soit accessible à tous et en particulier
aux jeunes c'est la finalité du
passculture
Cher il faut que ce soit un instrument
d'éducation un instrument d'éducation
populaire qu'elle participe de la
défense des valeurs auquel nous tenons
j'ai trop vu de jeunes se couper de
tout ne plus vouloir regarder la
télévision plus vouloir regarder des
films plus vouloir lire ne plus vouloir
écouter de la
musique
celle-ci sera l'une de mes priorités que
je partagerai avec ardeur avec ma
collègue ministre de l'éducation
nationale je crois aussi que le socle
essentiel de l'Europe c'est la culture
et c'est ce que nous avons en partage et
que nous devons faire vivre
ensemble c'est notre Constitution qui le
dit la nation garantit l'égal accès de
l'enfant et de l'adulte à la culture
tout est
dit ma ma nomination ici m rend
comptable je comprends qu'elle puisse
surprendre cette
nomination moi elle ne me surprend pas
elle répond à un véritable besoin le
besoin de la
France que souvent on dit
populaire parfois avec un petit peu de
maîpris je dois dire qui doit se sentir
représenté par mon parcours la culture
est un combat c'est un combat tous les
jours dans un monde où les défis sont
nombreux je demande si on aurait pas ici
la
radicalisation le communautarisme
séparatisme on
voit tout cela peut mener ma grande arme
est la combativité et je vais la mettre
au service de la culture de ses
représentants de ses professionnels de
ses
artistes et plus largement des Français
qui besoin de plus de culture de plus
accès à cette
culture vous l'urez deviné mais je
peut-être pas besoin de vous le dire je
je suis déterminé déterminé à agir
déterminé à écouter parliz tout àheure
de
d'étiquette c'est que le début
r Je suis déterminé à agir effectivement
et écouter tous les acteurs de la
culture de notre pays je veux pour
terminer mon propos saluer tous les
agents de ce ministère vous l'avez
rappelé des établissements
publics ils peuvent compter sur mon
énergie sur ma ténacité sur ma
détermination à travailler au service de
la
République pour ce magnifique bien
commun que la culture je vous
remercie je comprends que ma nomination
puiss surprendre moi elle ne me surprend
pas voilà ce que dit Rachid hadti un ton
très grave pour la nouvelle ministre de
la Culture qui tranche
avec la liberté la le sourire de Rima
abdoumak qui elle a défendu son bilan
avec ses mots je suis resté libre dans
mes engagements dans mes prises de
position voilà ce qu'on peut retenir de
cette première prise de parole
Emmanuel un premier mot sur ce que vous
venez d'entendre de la part de Rachida
Dati alors Rachida Dati oui elle elle
pose ses jalou on a bien entendu aussi
euh on comprend bien qu'elle peut se
servir de ce mandat de ministre de la
culture notamment à Paris avec la la
inauguration de Notre-Dame de Paris qui
sera un moment important sur lequel elle
pourra évidemment surfer en vue de des
prochaines municipal euh donc on a eu
deux un exercice assez classique mais
une sortante qui se sent obligé de
longuement défendre son propre bilan
tout particulièrement elle l'a fait
ardemment hein euh en disant d'ailleurs
qu'elle espère qu'il y aura l'amour
après le discrédit hein vous savez ce
poème de Shedid qu'elle cite à la fin
l'amour après le discrédit ben c'est
tout ce qu'on peut lui souhaiter euh et
on n' pas à rappeler mais c'est vrai que
ces difficultés Rima Abdul Malak avec le
président de la République sont faites
sur deux thèmes le premier c'était cette
affaire de par Dieu vous savez elle
avait elle
manifesté des critiques très fortes à
l'égard de de la du du du comédien
l'acteur et Emmanuel Macron avit pris le
le contrepied de cette position là en la
recadrant sévèrement et il y avait un
autre sujet sur lequel s'était exprimé
au Guy aussi c'était sur le le texte
immigration elle avait pris des
positions qui avaient été malvé c'est
deux sujets forts qui ont fait que elle
a elle a pas pu être maintenue à ce
poste là aussi manuel juste une petite
image quand même on attend dans un
instant parce que les passations de
pouvoir s'enchaînent la prise de parole
d'Amélie oua casterra et celle de
Gabriel Atal l'ancien ministre de
l'éducation nationale qui laisse donc sa
place à la ministre au super ministère
de des Jeux Olympiques des Sports et de
l'éducation nationale et puis une autre
image aussi également là on est au qu
d'orsé avec Catherine Colona qui va
laisser sa place à Stéphane ses journé
je vous laisse poursuivre parce qu'on on
revient quand même un instant sur le les
mots de Rachid Dati pour les femmes elle
l'a répété à nombreuses reprises
l'entreprise de séduction de ce
ministère un peu particulier a commencé
elle se positionne aussi elle cite pas
cheid mais elle cite Maler et elle se
positionne dans la
lignée d' hérit ge et en même temps elle
elle veut s'afficher comme à la fois
féministe et aussi populaire
hein elle-même répétant assez souvent
qu'elle est issue de cette de ces
milieux populaires et qu'elle auquel
elle veut elle veut répondre aujourd'hui
dit-elle et notamment à travers le
ministère de la Culture et c'est
l'occasion aussi pour elle de dire
qu'elle que son tempérament de
combattante elle compte le mettre au
service de cette nouvelle mission reste
à savoir comment ce sera perçu dans les
milieux culturels oui évidemment elle a
tenté de de justifier d'une certaine
manière sa nomination d'ailleurs sur le
sur le poste hein parce que Rachid é au
ministère de la culture c'est pas
évident elle ne s'est pas épanché sur la
question politique pas vraiment en tout
cas non non non elle a pas pas elle elle
a pas intérêt trop à aller sur ce
terrain là c'est c'est un peu compliqué
parce que à droite évidemment ce qu'elle
a choisi de faire Rachid hadti en
rejoignant ce gouvernement est vécu
comme une une trahison coup de poignard
dans le dos entendaiton hier soir à
droite chez les républicains oui alors
on va suivre les premierers pas de de
Rashid adati elles ont tenté toutes les
deux Rima abdoumak et rachidti de se
trouver des points d'accord pas certains
qu' en a réellement elles sont très
différentes hein elles se sont parlé
l'une l'autre je sais que vous serez
très en avant dans la lutte pour voilà
mais on sent bien qu'elles sont très
différentes on est dans la on est
évidemment dans la la théâtralisation
unee séquence d'un passage de relais qui
se veut aussi très diplomatique on n'est
pas là pour régler des comptes même si
on est très différent sur plan politique
évidemment merci beaucoup Emmanuel
galero merci d'être venu nous parler de
Rachid adati c'était la première
passation de pouvoir importante ce matin
deux images je vous remontre ici le le
ministère de l'Éducation nationale où
dans un instant Amélie oua Castera
prendra la parole à la suite de Gabriel
Atal et puis ici le ministère des
Affaires étrangères on sait que c'est
important mais qui risque d'être éclipsé
on va naviguer entre les deux vous
restez avec nous et puis on aura de
nouveaux intervenants on sera on va
essayer d'être en direct depuis la la la
cour de du ministère de l'Éducation
nationale parce que c'est une passation
très attendue évidemment merci manuel je
vous laisse pour l'instant avec les les
images de l'éducation
nationale
sommes toujours en direct emmanuelalo
vient de nous quitter ce sont les images
que vous voyez de l'éducation nationale
mais on change un instant de ministère
on reviendra sur l'éducation nationale
parce que c'est une passation qui nous
intéresse tout particulièrement mais
regardez ces imag au k d'orsé avec la
passation entre la nouvelle le nouveau
ministre des Affaires étrangères qui
prend la place de Catherine Colona
Stéphane journé qu'oncoute juste après
la
ministreessortante que de conduire la
diplomatie de la France sous l'autorité
du président de la République depuis le
mois de mai
2022 et venant de cette maison il ne
pouvait y avoir en vérité de plus grand
honneur et j'exprime mon immense
gratitude au chef de l'État et la
première ministre auprès desqueles j'ai
mené une mission si importante pour la
France dans dans un moment de si grande
violence dans le
monde mais c'est aussi comme femme que
je voudrais m'exprimer je vais commencer
par cela en soulignant un
fait je fus la deuxième seulement à
occuper ce poste un poste qui a compté
tant et tempant de titulaires depuis
tant et temps de
siècles dans ces fonctions j'ai eu à
cœur d'affirmer l'évidence à savoir que
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
peut aussi et doit aussi s'exprimer au
cœur du domaine régalien où se joue la
défense des intérêts les plus
fondamentaux de notre nation les femmes
ont leur place partout en France et
c'est une chance pour ce pays que de ne
négliger aucun de ses talents il
reviendra désormais à un homme ch
Stéphane séjourné de faire vivre la
cause de l'égalité et je ne doute pas
que tu le feras avec la même conviction
que celle qui m'a
animé en une vingtaine de mois j'ai pu
mesurer de nouveau combien le ministère
des Affaires étrangères est un lieu
d'excellence un de ces lieux
d'excellence tels que la France sait les
produire lorsque on combine exigence
permanente de la rigueur et la
créativité et la capacité d'initiative
qui sont sa marque j'ai donc une pensée
toute particulière sur ce thème de
l'excellence pour nos équipes qui à kè à
cartum à Niamé en Israël dans les
territoires palestiniens ont porté haut
les couleurs de notre pays et ont tenu
quand il le fallait sous les bombes
parfois ça veut dire que partout les
Français peuvent compter sur des
diplomates qui les protègent aux
familles de nos trois otages à Gaza je
veux dire je veux redire que l'État
continuera
demain comme hier à tout faire pour
qu'ils retrouvent leur proche à nos
compatriotes retenu dans les JA
iraniennes je dis aussi que nous faisons
tout pour mettre un terme à l'injustice
dont ils sont
victimes depuis plusieurs années les
Français
constatent les effets de la montée de la
violence dans le monde une violence
désinhibée une brutalité
assumée et à la tête de la diplomatie
française j'ai pu voir que ce voile de
dureté de férocité recouvrait chaque
jour davantage le monde en 20 mois j'ai
vu s'ajouter à la guerre en Ukraine qui
constitue en elle-même une rupture
profonde de l'ordre juridique moral
politique et sécuritaire sur lequel
était bâti notre cadre international et
qui est une menace pour notre propre
sécurité n noutons pas un instant j'ai
vu s'ajouter à cette guerre les assaut
contre nos ambassades au Burkina et au
Niger la progression du terrorisme au
Sahel et le départ de nos forces de
cette partie de
l'Afrique nous avons vu aussi une
nouvelle guerre civile sanglante ravager
le Soudan les colonnes de Prigogine
marchai sur Moscou les miliciens outil
s'en prendre au commerce international
en mer
Rouge la désinformation menacé nos
démocratie et nous avons vu le 7
octobre la barbarie des massacres commis
par le Hamas en cette journée du 7
octobre marque évidemment toute
conscience humaine mais nous marque nous
Français particulièrement aussi 41 de
nos compatriotes ont perdu la vie dans
ces attaques terroristes ces trois
derniers mois quatre fois je me suis
rendu dans la région et quatre fois j'ai
vu combien la violence terroriste du
Hamas avait tragiquement coûté à Israël
comme aux Palestiniens et j'ai voulu
démontrer que l'on peut être solidaire
des deux
peuples reconnaître le droit évident des
Israéliens à assurer leur sécurité et à
se défendre et reconnaître que les
souffrances palestiniennes sont
excessives et que le souhait simple de
vivre sur sa propre terre doit enfin
aboutir un État
palestinien auprès des familles des
victimes auprès des enquêteurs chargés
de documenter les crimes sexuels abject
commis en particulier contre les femmes
israéliennes auprès des Palestiniens
chassé de leur terre par des colons
extrémistes j'ai voulu porter la voix
singulière de la France je fait à ma
manière en disant ce qui devait l'être
ce que nous pensons ce en quoi nous
croyons ce que nous
faisons l'empathie la morale mais aussi
les rapports de force et le respect du
droit peuvent être énoncé clairement
mais avec le timbre calme de celui ou de
celle qui sait être dans le
juste car la justice au fond c'est le
critère de la politique étrangère que
j'ai voulu concevoir et ça n'est pas de
la naïveté c'est notre
force au côté des femmes iraniennes au
afghan trouvant refuge en France au côté
des Nations Unies sur le terrain au côté
des acteurs engagés partout pour la
justice pour les droits ou pour
l'environnement plus que jamais notre
réseau diplomatique s'ouvre au
partenariat avec ces acteurs en Afrique
notamment la la rénovation de notre
politique a connu une très nette
accélération dans le Pacifique le
triplement de notre investissement
solidaire nous permettra d'agir au
soutien des pays menacés par les effets
du changement climatique donc nous
sommes de ce
côté pour que la justice prévale il lui
faut parfois s'appuyer sur la puissance
ou même sur la force face à la violence
l'ordre juste doit être capable de
s'imposer ceux qui déportent des enfants
envahissent leurs voisins manipulent les
prix de l'énergie ou à femme pour à
servir pour
humilier doivent être tenus en
échec la France a un rôle à jouer pour
ça elle compte parmi les grands au côté
de ses alliés les États-Unis ou l'Inde
face à ses concurrents comme la Chine ou
d'autres
elle agit au renforcement d'une
Europe qui tarde encore à s'affirmer
autant qu'il le faudrait comme une
puissance géopolitique malgré nos appels
et nos
avertissements alors beaucoup a été fait
bien entendu en matière de politique
étrangère ou de défense ou dans la mise
en œuvre de l'agenda de souveraineté de
Versailles sous l'impulsion du Président
de la République mais le monde bouge on
voit qu'il se fait qu'il se des faits
qui se recomposent et nous savons donc
tout ce que beaucoup doit encore être
fait si nous ne voulons pas risquer de
disparaître en tant qu'Européen les
affaires du monde les élections
européennes de juin prochain doivent
aussi porter sur ce choix clair au
réarmement de l'Europe doit évidemment
répondre un réarmement de la nation
c'est le cap fixé à raison par le
Président de la République dès mon
arrivée au kéersé j'ai plaidé justement
en utilisant ce même mot de réarmement
pour un réarmement d'une diplomatie qui
avait été trop affaiblie par des années
et des années de coupe budgétaire et des
décennies de perte d'emploi qui tenait
de la véritable mutilation pour un pays
qui a toujours été grand aussi par son
rapport au monde et par son génie
diplomatique la France n'est pas
vraiment la France sans sa diplomatie et
une diplomatie en bonne place c'est le
propre des très grandes nations comme la
nôtre je suis reconnaissante au
président de la République et à notre
nouveau Premier ministre alors ministre
des comptes publicqus ainsi qu'à la
première ministre eth borne d'avoir
validé une hausse substantielle et
pluriannuelle des moyens humains et
financiers de ce ministère dès cette
année vous le savez cette haosse aura
des effets tangibles pour ceux qui sont
chargés de défendre les intérêts de
notre pays au qure co du monde et vous
aurez la charge cher Stéphane de
poursuivre sur cette voie ainsi
ouverte pour
résumer je suis t dire que je vous
laisse ainsi un ministère en meilleur
ordre et un monde trop en désordre ne
m'en veuillez pas et tous mes vœux vous
accompagnent pour que ce dernier soit
mieux ordonné et plus harmonieux et
avant que vous vous lanciez dans cette
tâche permettez-moi de remercier ceux
qui m'ont accompagné à la tête de ce
ministère mon cabinet bien sûr des
secrétaires d'État Laurence boun et
chisoua zacaropouou merci Laurence merci
Chris et le ministre délégué Olivier BCH
merci Olivier je veux remercier tous les
agents d'un ministère où seul compte la
loyauté
l'efficacité l'engagement au service de
la France et j'en ai côtoyé non
seulement des centaines depuis un mois
mais des milliers depuis plus de 40 ans
chaque visage chaque histoire est unique
mais ensemble il forme une mosaïque
toute française dans la file de l'école
républicaine que je suis a eu l'honneur
de faire partie et dont le tout fait de
notre pays un grand pays dans le concert
des nations un grand pays monsieur le
ministre le Premier ministre rappelait
le 9 janvier qu'il n'y a rien de plus
beau de plus grand et de plus fort que
de servir la France et les Français je
suis heureuse et Fiè d'avoir pu servir
mon pays et mes compatriotes et je suis
honoré chers amis de l'avoir fait avec
vous avec vous tous ensemble
madame la ministre Catherine
Colona monsieur le ministre mesdames les
secrétaires d'État Mesdames et Messieurs
les Ambassadeurs chers amis je mesure
l'honneur qui m'est fait aujourd'hui
représenter mon pays euh dans le mande
porter tu l'as dit Catherine sa voix
singulière sa conception de la dignité
humaine est une charge lourde alors je
remercie le président de la République
et et le Premier ministre pour pour leur
confiance je sais aussi au vu des
portraits de mes prédécesseurs euh que
la tâche sera lourde que la confiance
est immense il s'agit d'être à la
hauteur des des femmes et des hommes qui
ont façonné l'image de la France dans le
monde et donc aussi l'image que nous les
Français nous faisons de notre pays être
à la hauteur de leur engagement et en
particulier du tien chère Catherine il
fallait du sang froid tu l'as dit pour
et la détermination pour mener la
diplomatie française dans des vents
mauvais
merci pour ton action résolue au service
de l'intérêt de notre pays une action
résolue dans notre soutien au peuple
ukrainien et auprès également du peuple
arménien une action aussi pour tenir la
position d'équilibre si cher à la France
au Proche Orient une action résolue dans
la lutte contre le terrorisme tu as
renforcé nos partenariats pour mieux
protéger les Français pendant cette
période une action résolue dans les
négociations aussi internationales pour
le climat et la biodiversité et je veux
saluer
peut-être ton héritage sur le volet de
la diplomatie
féministe tu l'as évoqué également une
ambition que nous partageons d'ailleurs
et je souhaite d'ailleurs renforcer un
certain nombre
d'initiatives alors j'ai désormais la
lourde
responsabilité de continuer ce travail
je le sais je ne suis pas diplomate de
métier mais ayant grandi à l'étranger je
sais que ce que je veux dire aussi la
France dans le monde je connais aussi
tout le pouvoir de la négociation de la
diplomatie la négociation européenne a
été pour moi le lieu de tous les
possibles j'ai intimement le sentiment
qu'il est possible de réunir les points
de vue les plus opposés par le dialogue
par l'effort de convaincre et de
comprendre l'autre c'est à la lumière de
cette conviction que j'entends serv et
guider l'action de ce ministère je sais
que je pourrais compter sur le travail
et l'expertise de milliers d'agents du
ministère des Affaires étrangèr
diplomate expert agents de l'État à
l'étranger ils sont la matrice de la
puissance de la France et de sa capacité
à agir partout où l'intérêt national est
en jeu je compte sur eux pour mener à
bien la feuille de route du président de
la République cette feuille de route
celle d'une Europe puissante mais
notamment une France indépendante dans
une Europe nous interrompons Stéphane
sjourné le nouveau ministre des Affaires
étrangère Emmanuel Rivière vous êtes
avec nous mais on se rend au ministère
de l'Éducation nationale Gabriel Atal c
sa place à améliie cter on en parle dans
un instant chers directeur directrice et
agent du ministère de l'Éducation
nationale mesdames et
messieurs vous le savez je l'ai dit ici
en prenant m fonctions de ministre de
l'éducation nationale et de la jeunesse
il y a à peu près 6 mois je crois
profondément qu'il n'y a pas plus beau
pas de plus grand combat que celui de
l'école l'école c'est le lieu où les
consciences se forment et se forge le
lieu où la jeunesse grandit apprend
conquère sa liberté c'est là où l'on
insuple la confiance et où les talents
de chacun peuvent
s'épanouir chaque enfant rentre à
l'école avec un talent quelque chose en
plus que les autres et le rôle de
l'école le plus beau de tous c'est de
l'aider à révéler ce
talent l'école c'est aussi le fruit de
notre histoire le reflet de la nation et
le ciment de notre République à l'école
seul le savoir et le travail compte à
l'école nos valeurs transmettent et
raonn dans ch de classe cherre améie tu
l'as compris et tu le sais tu le
partages l'école est le trésor
inestimable de notre République c'est
pourquoi depuis 2017 le président de la
République en a fait une priorité
absolue c'est pourquoi comme je l'ai dit
dès mon arrivée à Matignon l'école sera
la mère des batailles de mon
gouvernement et j'en serai le garant au
moment de te transmettre le témoin je
veux dire mon immense
reconnaissance d'abord à tous les
professeurs et tous les personnels de
l'Éducation nationale de France chaque
jour dans chaque salle de classe dans
chaque établissement vous accomplissez
la plus précieuse des missions
transmettre chaque jour vous contribuez
à changer la vie d'élève à accompagner à
déjouer les destins tracés écrits par
avance en arrivant dans ce ministère je
l'ai dit et je le réitère aujourd'hui
vous faites le plus beau métier du monde
cette conviction aujourd'hui je l'ai
plus encore chevillé au corps je vous
connais j'ai entendu vos doutes vos
inquiétudes vos colères parfois mais
aussi vos espoirs et votre détermination
toujours je garde avec moi vos
témoignages et nos échanges ils ne me
quittent pas et ils ne me quitteront
jamais tout ce que nous avons entamé ira
jusqu'au bout je m'y engage et je serai
toujours à vos côtés
je veux dire ma reconnaissance aussi à
toutes celles et ceux avec qui j'ai
travaillé avec qui nous avons posé les
fondements d'une action renouvelée et
ambitieuse pour l'école et pour notre
jeunesse ch Caro je pense à la réforme
majeure et nécessaire du lycée
professionnel que nous avons engagé je
te remercie pour l'énergie déployée sur
ce chantier ch Priska je pense au
travail remarquable mené pour notre
jeunesse et pour ce projet qui nous
tient tant à cœur service national
universel pour notre vie associative
aussi je pense à toutes les directions
du ministère à ces directrice et
directeur tu le verras chère Amélie tu
seras parfaitement entouré et tu pourras
compter sur des administrations
remarquable et
engagé je pense bien entendu à mon
cabinet qui n'a économisé ni les heures
je le sais ni les efforts et qui a
accompli un travail absolument
exceptionnel
quand je suis arrivé dans ces murs j'ai
voulu lancer un certain nombre de
chantiers beaucoup nous ont dit c'est
pas possible vous n'yarz pas et pourtant
en 6 mois à peine nous avons non
seulement engagé des chantiers mais pris
des décision for et nous les avons fait
appliquer j'ai affirmé mon soit de
reconquérir le mois de juin pour que
tous les élèves puisse être en formation
en cours jusqu'à la fin de l'année
scolaire nous l'avons
fait
j'ai décalé les épreuves de spécialité
du baccalauréat du mois de mars Au mois
de juin pour la première fois je CIS que
c'est ass inédit j'ai décider que le
brevet se tiendrait non plus en juin
mais tout début juillet pour que nos
collégiens soi en cours jusqu'à la fin
du mois de
juin et tous les élèves de Seconde
réaliseront un stage en entreprise parce
que je crois profondément que c'est un
élément majeur pour notre politique
d'orientation nous l'avons fait en
arrivant dans ces murs j'ai voulu
réaffirmer une valeur absolument
fondamental pour notre République la
laïcité et faire pleinement appliquer la
loi de 2004 en interdisant le port de
laaba et du camis beaucoup m'ont dit ça
n'est pas possible on pourraz pas le
faire nous l'avons fait il n'y a plus
d'Aba et plus de camis dans nos
établissements scolaires et le combat
pour la laïcité à l'école et dans la
République évidemment se poursuit il
reste temps à faire et nous y
travaillerons ensemble chers amis quand
je suis arrivé ici j'ai appelé de mes
vœux un électrochoc sur la question du
harcèlement scolaire j'ai demandé que la
peur change de camp beaucoup m'ont dit
ça n'est pas possible bien désormais il
y a une règle claire et qui s'est
appliqué à de très nombreuses reprises
déjà malheureusement si je puis dire ça
n'est plus à l'élève harcelé de fuir son
établissement scolaire c'est un l'élève
harceleur de quitter son établissement
et de laisser ses victime tranquille
nous l'avons fait quand je suis arrivé
ici j'ai dit à avec lucidité que nous
pouvions nous satisfaire d'une
diminution du niveau de nos élèves j'ai
pris un certain nombre de décisions
fortes elles s'appliquent et elles
commenceront à s'appliquer dès cette
année d'abord faire la vérité la
transparence sur le niveau réel de nos
élèves c'est une méthode que
j'appliquerai systématiquement sur tous
les chantiers de mon gouvernement la
lucidité dire les choses les Français
sont intelligents ils savent ce qui se
joue partout dans notre pays
ou
le niveau de nos élèves a diminué ces
dernières décennies et nous pouvons nous
en réjouir c'est un enjeu pour l'avenir
de notre pays il a des signes d'espoir
grâce à l'action résolue qui a été
engagé par le président de la République
en 2017 pour l'école primaire nous
commençons à mesurer des
effets il y a moins d'élèves aujourd'hui
qui rentrent en 6e avec très grandes
difficultés de lecture d'écriture et de
calcul qu'il en avait en 2017 mais il en
encore beaucoup trop il faut
poursuivre et pour poursuivre il faut je
le dis ici remettre de l'exigence à tous
les étages de la transparence et de
l'exigence je l'ai dit un
diplôme qui a du sens c'est un diplôme
qui a des conséquences et j'ai donc
décidé cela s'applique une
nouvelle organisation de notre brevet
des
collèges pour que tous les élèves
travaillent pour obtenir leur diplôme
dès cette année dès la session du brevet
du mois de
juin j'ai décidé que les correctifs
académiques seraient supprimés cette
pratique qui consistait pour atteindre
un niveau un taux de réussite très élevé
à gonfler artificiellement les notes de
nos élèves
J et je
l'assume certains me disent le taux de
réussite au Brevet va donc mécaniquement
diminuer oui je l'assume mais pour moi
ce n'est pas un taux de réussite qui
diminuera c'est un taux de réussite qui
sera rapprochera de la réalité du niveau
de nos élèves et si nous ne prenons pas
des décisions comme celle-ci qui sont
évidemment difficiles nous n'arriverons
pas à rétablir l'exigence et
l'excellence à tous les étages j'assume
aussi cette décision de la même manière
j'ai décidé de mettre en place les
groupes de niveau au collège en français
et en mathématiques beaucoup de M dit ça
n'est pas possible de décider d'une
mesure comme celle-ci je l'ai fait
beaucoup m'ont dit ça ne sera pas
possible à mettre en place parce qu'il
faut des créations de postes
supplémentaires parce qu'évidment les
élèves les plus en difficulté doivent
apprendre dans des groupes à taille
réduite j'ai obtenu de la première
ministre de l'époque la création de
postes supplémentaires pour y parvenir
ça peut donc pas trop diser chère
Amélie mais je seraiis tu l'as compris
évidemment toujours attentif parce que
l'école dispose des moyens nécessaires
pour son
action ce ministère c'est celui c'est
aussi celui du dialogue et de la
construction commune je veux saluer les
organisations syndicales je crois à la
franchise et au résultats vous aussi
c'est dans cet état d'esprit que j'ai
abordé nos échanges n notre dialogue a
été nourri riche continu grâce à cela
beaucoup de choses ont pu avancer je
veux enfin remercier les parlementaires
engagés pour l'éducation nationale leur
investissement est déterminant le
travail main dans la main avec les
parlementaires de tout bord est une des
clés du succès de l'école de la même
manière que le travail avec nos élus
locaux qui ont la responsabilité pour
les maires de nos écoles pour les
présidents de départ de nos collèges et
les présidents de région de nos lycées
est absolument indispensable mesdames
messieurs vous l'aurez compris
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas une page qui se
tourne c'est une action qui se poursuit
et qui s'accélère encore car la
continuité c'est bien une question de
détermination et d'idée aujourd'hui je
le dis j'ai confiance la détermination
chère Amélie tu l'as tu l'as prouvé à
chaque étape de ton parcours tu as une
rage de vaincre et une insatiable envie
de servir tu as montré que comme
ministre des Sports et des Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques que tu étais
capable de préparer les plus grandes
échéances tout en te souciant des enjeux
du quotidien tu as prouvé que tu étéis
déterminé à faire bouger les lignes à
briser les overpas à refuser les
discriminations et les violence je sais
que tu auras à cœur de continuer ces
combats aussi ici je sais aussi tout le
travail que nous avons déjà accompli
ensemble au service du sport à l'école
tu as beaucoup d'ambition pour la
pratique sportive de nos élèves te voilà
la nette pour les concrétiser quant au
Cap cher Amélie il n'a pas changé d'un
yota c'est celui fixé par le président
de la République un cap que nous
tiendrons avec ambition et Constance toi
ici et moi à Matignon nous continuerons
à agir pour élever le niveau scolaire le
choc des savoirs se mettra en œuvre et
portera ses fruits il en va de l'avenir
de notre jeunesse et du futur de notre
pays nous continuerons à construire une
école des droits et des devoirs où le
respect de l'autorité de l'enseignant
est une valeur cardinale où les valeurs
de la République ne sont pas négociables
où l'on réagit vite et où l' prend des
décisions fermes une école où le pas de
vague n'a pas sa place nous continuerons
également à construire une école où
chaque élève peut être heureux on ne
peut pas apprendre avec la peur au
ventre alors n nous poursuivrons la
lutte sans merci que nous menons contre
le harcèlement scolaire tu sais combien
ce combat me tient à cœur et je l'emmène
aussi avec moi à matigon et tu me
trouvera à tes côté pour agir sur ce
sujet enfin comme cela a été le cas par
le passé tu auras ta responsabilité non
seul l'éducation et la jeunesse mais
aussi les sports et les jeux
paralmpiques je connais parfaitement les
dossiers et les enjeux cet été le monde
entier regardera la France je sais ta
détermination à faire de ces jeux un
succès je sais aussi ton attachement à
faire vivre l'élan olympique àce qu'il
donne le goût du sport à notre jeunesse
à toute notre société à ce qu'il
fortifie nos clubs et nos associations
sportives depuis Juvenal nous savons
combien le corps et l'esprit vont de
terre c'est un peu l'idéal qu'incarne ce
ministère
ch amée mesdames et messieurs avant de
passer le témoin je voudrais avoir un
dernier
moterot pour qui
vivreolair
surtau professeurs
éid CP
pirmiolair personnel de direction les
proviseurs
lespau je veux le dire
que je continuerai à les servir que je
continuerai à agir pour eux à tes côtés
cher Amélie et que tu me tra toujours à
tes côtés pour avancer sur ces questions
je veux avoir un mot pour tous les
parents d'élèves pour tous les élèves de
France je serai toujours de votre côté
sous l'g du président de la République
nous avons lancé des réformes
importantes pris des décisions fortes
pour notre école nous les mènerons à
leur terme nous réussirons ensemble j'en
ai pris l'engagement devant vous alors
je le tiendrai cher amé j'ai confiance
je compte sur toi et tu l'as compris tu
peux compter sur moi je vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
remercie
Monsieur le Premier Ministre mesdames
les ministres cher Carole cher Prisc
Mesdames et Messieurs les recteurs chè
directrices chers directeurs chers
agents du ministère chers familles chers
amis merci Monsieur le Premier Ministre
pour votre vision pour ces mots pour vos
encouragements merci à vous et au
président de la républ public pour la
confiance que vous m'accordez c'est pour
moi un honneur immense de prendre la
tête de ce ministère d' l'éducation
nationale de la jeunesse des sports et
des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques la République vous l'avez
dit est d'abord l'histoire d'une
promesse celle de permettre à chaque
enfant à chaque jeune de devenir un
citoyen libre et éclairé un individu
instruit mais aussi épanoui en
réunissant ces champs de l'éducation
nationale du sport de la jeunesse dans
notre contexte olympique et paralympique
le président de la République et
vous-même monsieur le Premier ministre
m'avez confié un continuum de
responsabilité de politique publique aux
synergies nombreuses qui doit nous
permettre de tenir cette promesse
républicaine pour notre jeunesse et ce
continuum avec le sport et les jeux se
prolongent vers la Nation toute
entière c'est en empreinte de beaucoup
d'humilité que je vous succède chère
Gabrielle sur ce périmètre vous qui avez
en si peu de temps
profondément profondément marqué la
trajectoire de cette grande institution
qui est l'éducation national par une
série de décisions et d'actes forts que
je pourrais synthétiser comme le refus
de tous les statutco de tous les
affaissements de tous les faux semblants
de toutes les violences
et je sais que vous aurez à cœur de
m'accompagner et même de me
coacher ma feuille de route sur ce
périmètre éducation nationale et
jeunesse est claire elle est celle que
vous avez porté ces derniers mois avec
une exceptionnelle vigueur guidé par le
cap depuis 2007 fixé 2017 fixé par le
président de la
République qui depuis le premier jour
fait de l'école ça grande
priorité alors je sais d'abord les
attentes immenses celles de tous ceux à
commencé par les enseignants les chefs
d'établissement les recteurs et toutes
leurs équipes qui incarnent et font
vivre notre service public de
l'éducation celle aussi des parents
d'élèves dont je connais et dont je
partage les préoccupations il les attend
aussi sans qu'il l'exprime toujours
de nos élèves
eux-mêmes je sais les traumatismes qui
ont toucher le cœur même de notre école
donc de la République avec les
assassinats de Samuel Patier de
Dominique Bernard mais aussi les
suicides de Lucas de Linc de Nicolas ou
la tentative de suicide encore avantti
d'un jeune lycéen au lycée Stéphane
esselle de
Toulouse je sais les inquiétudes les
doutes les frustrations ce climat
scolaire trop souvent dégradé tant pour
le corps enseignant que pour les
familles autant de difficultés trop
longtemps
éludé enfermé muré dans un pas de vague
qui n'a satisfait personne chè Gabriel
vous avez mis fin à cela enenant un
discours de vérité et je veux que chacun
sache que cette ligne je la suivrai
comme je l'ai fait depuis le premier
jour avec et pour le monde du sport pour
sortir des difficulté est redonner à
notre école toute la confiance et l'élan
qu'elle mérite nous devons agir
vite avec le sens partager des urgences
et des priorités et en même temps nous
savons que l'éducation s'entre
nécessairement dans le temps long grâce
à l'engagement de toutes les forces
vives de ce ministère dans la durée
patiemment et grâce à l'amour des
professeurs pour leur méti
à leurs
expériences et en tête cette double
temporalité et avec cet appétit que je
partage avec vous pour l'action et les
résultats je poursuivrai vos chantiers
Monsieur le Premier Ministre jusqu'au
succès et au service de ce que le
président de la République a appelé le
réarmement civique de notre jeunesse et
qui passera par trois
piliers d'abord vous l'avez dit
restaurer l'exigence fondé sur le choc
des savoirs et sur l'autorité réaffirmée
de nos professeurs qui doivent comme
toute la communauté éducatif pouvoir
exercer leur métier dans un cadre apaisé
serein respectueux et à cet égard je le
dis il ne doit y avoir aucune place pour
la peur dans l'école de la
République deuxè pilier régénérer le
métier d'enseignant à travers une
attractivité renforcée qui passe
notamment par le chantier de la
formation initiale et par la poursuite
des réformes engagées sur la
revalorisation des carrières qui doit
nous permettre aussi de mieux résoudre
ce problème structurel des heures non
remplacé et donc perdu pour
l'édification de notre
jeunesse enfin nous devons construire
plus que jamais une école de
l'épanouissement républicain une école
dans lesquelle les élèves s'approprient
les valeurs de la République à commencé
par la laïcité ind de notre liberté et
les valeurs de l'engagement avec le
service national universel une école qui
ne transige jamais sur le respect de
l'enfant et refuse catégoriquement le
harcèlement pas de place à l'école pour
la peur pas de place non plus à l'école
pour le malheur une école ens suite où
chacun trouve sa place y compris et plus
que jamais nos élèves en situation de
handicap et leurs
accompagnants une école qui regarde avec
avec la même considération tous les
parcours et qui valorise notamment nos
lycéens professionnels une école
attentive à la santé de l'enfant grâce à
l'action quotidienne des médecins des
infirmiers scolaires et demain leurs
conditions physiques avec nos
professeurs de PS et enfin et peut-être
plus encore une école qui s'est
identifieré et reconnaître les
singularités de nos enfants qui sait
faire grandir leurs talents dans le
théâtre la musique la danse le dessin ou
le sport nous devons accompagner ces
enfants dans leur passion et permettre
enfin vraiment dans notre pays ce double
projet académique d'un côté artistique
ou sportif de l'autre à l'ensemble de la
communauté
éducative je veux dire ce matin ma
fierté de pouvoir travailler avec elle
je serai à l'écoute de ce de ses
représentants et de ses acteurs de
terrain farouchement engager à leur côté
à vos côtés à tous pour que l'école
renoue avec l'égalité des chances et
pour que fortifié sur son socle de
valeur et de fondamentaux elle continue
à innover et à
s'ouvrir et en cette année de jeux
olympiques et paralympique je
continuerai aussi à mettre en œuvre avec
le même enthousiasme la feuille de route
que je porte avec et pour le sport
français depuis plus d'un an et demi
ces jeux à la maison qui vont inspirer
notre jeunesse quelle elle sera
associer nous allons les réussir nous
allons les réussir pour notre pays tout
entier qui a besoin de victoire et qui
peut compter sur un collectif de parties
prenant déterminé comme je le suis àce
que ces jeux soi grands et rendre des
Français
fiers agir pour le sport
c'est continuer de fortifier notre
modèle sportif dans toutes ses
composantes éthique intégrité bénévola
développement de la pratique avec nos
athlètes et avec le mouvement sportif
agir pour nos enfants c'est renforcer la
place du sport à l'école c'est pourquoi
je veux que notre devise lire écrire
compter s'enrichisse aussi du mot bouger
parce que la conjugaison des forces du
corps et de l'esprit ce fameux mensana
incorporéano permet de mieux se
construire jusqu'au bout affforcerie
dans un monde marqué par cette addiction
croissante aux écrans qui appe les
centre d'intérêt de nos
enfants cette place renouvelée du sport
à l'école elle s'appuie sur le socle de
l'EPS et des As mais aussi sur la
généralisation effective des 30 minutes
d'activité physique quotidienne au
primaire et sur le développement des
passerelles avec les clubs dans le cadre
du 8h 18h en Rep et REP plus ou pour nos
collégiens mais en cette année de
grandes causes nationales dédié pour la
première fois à l'activité physique et
sportive je veux rappeler bien sûr que
le sport n'est pas seulement bon pour
nos enfants mais pour tous nos
concitoyens parce qu'il contrecart la
sédentarité repousse les maladies
procure du bien-être et de la robustesse
et je veux rappeler dans cette
magnifique institution républicaine que
le sport mérite notre attention parce
qu'il est ce formidable vecteur de
mixité d'inclusion d'intégration dont
l'intention a
besoin pour
conclure permettez-moi une pensée ce
matin un tout petit peu plus personnelle
pour ma famille merci pour votre
exceptionnel
soutien pour mes trois garçons qui à
l'URE parlons sont à l'école comme 12
millions de nos enfants une pensée aussi
pour les professeurs dont petite j'ai eu
la chance de croiser la route à l'école
et sur les cours de tennis je veux leur
dire comme j'ai passionnément aimé tout
ce qu'ils m'ont appris la manière dont
de Madame hardarder à Monsieur Louis en
passant par les frères storet ils m'ont
aidé à trouver ma voix et je ferai en
sort dans mes fonctions que la petite
flamme qui a fait naître la vocation de
tous ces professeurs de tous nos
professeurs de métropole aux outr m elle
reste intacte vive
lumineuse l'école mesdames et messieurs
est une terre de
possible le sport est une terre de
possible la jeunesse a envie et besoin
de ces
possibles et la France les Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques en cette
année 2024 doit plus que jamais être
cette terre de possible alors oui oui la
tâche sera lourde et j'aurai besoin de
vous de toutes les équipes
exceptionnelles sur lesquelles j'ai pu
déjà m'appuyer et sur vous qui incarnez
ce service public de l'éducation
nationale lourde oui mais la feuille de
route monsieur le Premier ministre est
claire elle est essentielle et elle
mérite qu'ensemble tous ensemble nous la
portions à la réussite je vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
remercie une passation de pouvoir qui
n'en était pas vraiment une une ministre
sous tutelle qui a semblé faire
allégance à son premier ministre Gabriel
Atal a tutoyé Amélie ou casterra elle la
vous voyez voilà premiers enseignements
peut-être qu'on peut tirer de ces deux
prises de parole Emmanuel Rivière
bonjour vous êtes spécialiste de
l'opinion directeur associé chez dans
l'agence grand public qu'est-ce que vous
en avez pensé c'est assez étonnant c'est
la 4e passation de pouvoir cons suuit
depuis ce matin était très différente
des autres parce que là elle a
clairement pris les ordres améli
casterra non oui bah alors à la
différence des autres passations de
pouvoir euh c'est une passation de la
part de quelqu'un qui garde une partie
du pouvoir et qui l'a clairement dit
puisque ça va être le premier ministre
et je pense que et Gabriel Atal et
Amélie oua casterra avaiit à cœur de
répondre tout de suite à un certain
nombre de critiques qui ont succédé sa
nomination à lui à Matignon et puis sa
désignation à elle euh sur le thème bah
voilà c'est
l'éducation on en fait une grande cause
la mre de toutes les batailles a dit le
nouveau Premier ministre mais il n'y
aura passé que 6 mois et amie ou DEA
Castera elle va prendre la tête d'un
grand ministère qui associe les sports
et la la jeunesse et l'éducation ce qui
n'est pas du tout une nouveauté ce qui
est un peu nouveau c'est que on va pas
dire que les sports avalent l'éducation
mais souvent c'était un ministre
identifié éducation qui prenait les
sport et surtout bah il y a petite éché
au mois de juillet août qui s'appelle
les Jeux Olympiques oui parce que elle
est ministre de l'éducation nationale
des sports et des Jeux Olympiques juste
une précis et paralympique vous avez
raison de le préciser juste pour vous
donner les dernières informations cette
image du Palais de l'Élysée parce que
dans quelques minutes à 11h normalement
doit se tenir le premier Conseil des
ministres du gouvernement de Gabriel
Atal ça a visiblement pris un peu de
retard au ministère de l'Éducation
nationale mais on va voir arriver
progressivement les ministres les
nouveaux et puis les les Toer on suivra
ça attentivement ceux qui s'arrêtent sur
le perron pour faire une photo ou non
oui est-elle capable Amélie ou casterra
de je pense au mois de mai au mois de
juin au mois de juillet au mois d'août
des périodes décisives alors que les
Jeux Olympiques approcheront et auront
lieu de mener à bien une rentrée
scolaire est-ce qu'il va falloir mettre
sous tutelle à nouveau un secrétaire
d'État ministre délégué alors qu'on a
bien compris que le ministre de
l'éducation nationale resta quasiment
Gabriel Atal alors voilà Gabriel Atal
dit je vais continuer à suivre ça de
prèsera a donné dans son intervention
beaucoup de sens à le fait qu'une
sportive ministre des Sports prenne la
tête de l'éducation nationale donc lire
écrire compter et et bouger mais on peut
s'attendre à ce que elle soit épaulée
par effectivement un ministre délégé un
secrétaire d'État qui va s'occuper
spécialement ça le président de la
République avec Gabriel l qui a
clairement établi la feuille de route
plus que ne l'a fait Amélie UD casterra
Amélie Ouda casterra ministre titulaire
et en dessous un ministre délégué ou un
secrétaire d'État qui serait bien obligé
de gérer les affaires courantes alors
que la ministre sera clairement occupée
à l'organisation des Jeux Olympiques je
suis d'accord avec vous c'est c'est
c'est comme ça qu'on perd les enfants à
la plage he qu'il y a trop d'adultes qui
disent non non il y a pas de problème je
vais continuer à à bien suivre et à m'
et à m'en occuper euh alors on verra
ensuite comment les les choses les les
choses s'articulent euh ce qui quand
même étant en filigrane qui était pas du
tout dans la campagne d'Emmanuel Macron
en tout cas pas à ce point est pas
encore moins perçu à ce point par par le
le public c'est la recentralité de la
question de la jeunesse qui était plus
visible entre 2017 en 2022 que la
campagne de 2022 après la campagne de
2022 est évidemment parquée par les
événements internationaux de de la
période ce qui a été l'occasion pour
l'un comme pour l'autre quand même de
dire à quel point on on compte sur
l'éducation cela ils sont en phase avec
un état d'esprit du pays qui pense que
c'est à l'école d'accomplir non pas
simplement la transmission des
compétences scolaires lire écrire
compter donc désormais bougerir
fondamentaux devenir des bons citoyens
enfin on voit bien euh comment tout le
monde d'ailleurs c'est c'était le cas
aussi de de de de Rachid adati s'empare
du réarmement et le mot n'est pas du
tout n'est pas du tout neutre civique ce
qui veut dire qu'une fois de plus
Emmanuel Macron hein c'est l'un des
grands mots du président de la
République depuis quelques semaines
alors qu'une première voiture arrive
pardon dans la cour de l'Élysée qui est
le premier ministre le le faillot le
Premier ministre qui arrive au Conseil
des ministres et bien c'est ERC dupour
Moretti le ministre de la Justice qui
lui a con lui ntait pas embêté dans son
agenda ce matin par une passation de
pouvoir donc effectivement il avait
moins de mérite que d'autres à être à
l'URE pas si c'est la première fois
qu'on le voit parmi les drapeaux devant
l'Élysée il y a le drapeau français le
drapeau européen et le drapeau de Paris
2024 pour cette nouvelle année
visiblement ce drapeau sera associé
bon c'est vrai que on a on a les jeux à
l'horizon je suis pas sûr ministre de
l'Agriculture lui aussi son po ai on
continue à à regarder les arrivées des
différents ministres mais on parle de de
cette passation de pouvoir qui n'en
était pas vraiment une à à l'éducation
nationale Amélie oua casterra son
discours vous m'avez dit euh lorsqu'on
regardait qu'il pouvait plaire au profs
bah c'est un on l'a vu d'ailleurs y
compris précédemment lors des discours
de Catherine Colona et Stéphane séjourné
il faut pas oublier que les les gens
qu'on voit nous à l'écran ils ont en
face d'eux les personnels du ministère
vaillamment réunis par ce grand froid
dans la cour donc il parle aussi il
parle à des caméras mais il parle aussi
à leur administration oui il parle au
français au journalistes à leur
administration au Premier ministre qui
est juste à côté euh l'équilibre est
difficile voilà ensuite bon je pense
qu'il y a une volonté d'améie ou et Cera
bah de prendre la mesure de cet univers
dont elle n'est pas issue alors il y a
quelques petits signaux qui sont envoyés
rappeler qu'elle est elle-même GAB qui
arrive pardon pour son premier Conseil
des ministres en tant que Premier
ministre c'est allé vite il a quitté
rapidement la la rue de Grenel un petit
sourire oui et il s'arrête sur le perron
de l'Élysée et il rentre donc le sourire
était très furtif finalement très furtif
très concentré le là ça va être un
moment important on va en parler de
cette première réunion oui je vous
laisse poursuivre sur cette prise de
parole qui semble qui pourrait
satisfaire les profs bah disons qu' a
j'ai trouvé qu'il y avait davantage dans
la prise de parole d'amili ou de Castera
des références direct estce qu'il a
beaucoup secoué le monde enseignant je
suis obligé de vous couper à nouveau
mais catherrine vrein alors ça c'est une
entrée particulire on l'a pas vu ce
matin on n pas eu de passation de
pouvoir ministre importante la 4e dans
l' protocolaire du du gouvernement avec
le travail et la santé on rappelle hein
que Catherine vutterin avait été très
très très fortement pressenti pour être
premierre ministre en
2022 que cette ce scénario qui était
très avancé avait commencé à à contacter
des des gens pour constituer son cabinet
avait s'était heurté un tir de barrage
d'une partie des
des pilier de de de la macronie qui la
trouvait trop à droite et c'est vrai que
ça dans dans ce grand ministère bah
voilà ses pris de position notamment au
moment de de la manif pour tous contre
de la oui de la manif pour tous contre
le mariage pour tous avait été un des
arguments avancés en 2022 pour dire que
c'était difficilement compatible avec
son entrée au gouvernement en tout cas à
Matignon là elle n pas tout à fait
évidemment sur la même sur dans le même
dans le même positionnement oui elle
n'est pas zamatigon mais elle a un
ministère très important qu'on a là
aussi parfois du mal à lier peut-être
plus plus encore que les Jeux Olympiques
et l'éducation nationale la santé et le
travail oui alors là aussi on va voir
des secrétaires d'État des ministres
délégués elle va paser tout seul je
pense qu'il y a des précédents d'avoir
d'abord ce sont des des des c'est très
différent quand même non de ministères
opposé ouais c'est des ministères qui
ont des locaux et des administrations en
commun notamment un service de
communication en commun donc la
proximité entre les deux est un peu
aussi un peu aussi
fonctionnel il y a ce grand univers
cette dénomination commune d'ailleurs on
appelle ça les ministères sociaux et
avec beaucoup de passerelles parce que
la santé au travail faisant partie
faisant partie aussi des sujets il y a
toute la protection sociale qui est à la
fois un enjeu travail et un enjeu pour
la santé il se trouve que dans l'univers
de la santé il y a des lourdes questions
qui sont des questions de recrutement de
disponibilité de formation et cetera et
puis c'est alors le ministère c'est pour
ça que son profil est pas du tout anoda
c'est le ministère qui discute le plus
avec les partenaires sociaux les
ministères sociaux que seront les les
les syndicats ça c'est un peu une vraie
question quel sera le le profil de
ministre de Catherine vuterin aux yeux
des syndicats qui sont sortis he même si
ont pas obtenu g de cause plutôt
renforcé et dans l'opinion et dans y
compris auprès de leur réseau militant
de la séquence des retraites 10h57 nous
sommes toujours en direct après les
passations de pouvoirs des ministères
des ministères qui ont changé de tête ce
matin premier Conseil des ministres à
l'Élysée plusieurs ministres sont déjà
arrivés et débarquent à l'Élysée la
nouvelle porte-parole priscatevno alors
petite précision il nous est annoncé
pour l'instant qu'il n'y aura pas de
compte-rendu du conseil des ministre à
l'issue donc de la Réunion qui va se
tenir à l'Élysée pris catev ne devrait
donc pas faire sa première face à la
presse tout à l'heure on suivra ça
attentivement euh dans dans quelques
minutes intéressant cette première
réunion pour Gabriel hatal parce que on
le sait la question de sa légitimité se
pose il peut être bousculé par des
tolier par des nouveaux entrants on
pense à Rachid hadti est-ce qu'il va
devoir en conseil des ministres tout de
suite s'affirmer ou non là c'est la
place du président de la République en
fait ce qui va être intéressant c'est de
voir comment Emmanuel Macron se comporte
vis-à-vis de ce jeune premier ministre
oui c'est lui qui va finalement
déterminer tout ça souvent il y a une
forme de rival entre Maon et l'ésée et
puis d'abord évidemment dans les
premiers temps grandes embrassades tout
va bien et puis assez rapidement on voit
qu'il peut y avoir des tensions entre
les équipes et parfois même entre les
les les occupants du poste là on est
quand même dans quelque chose d'assez
inédit c'està-dire que le nouveau
Premier ministre je pense que ça n'est
jamais arrivé qu'il est passé si
longtemps en l'occurrence pas loin de 7
ans dans une ligne hiérarchique sous
l'autorité du Président de la République
pour cherch tous les premers ministres
qui ont été nommés sous la 5e République
il y a pas une telle continuité d'un
rapport de subordination si je peux dire
les choses comme ça entre celui qui est
qui arrive à Matignon et puis celui qui
l'a nommé Emmanuel arrivère Gérald
armanin qui arrive comme d'habitude à
pied de qui juste à côté juste à côté
200 m non on prend pas la voiture pour
ça c'est un gouvernement écolo avec un
premier ministre également en charge de
la transition écologique général d'manin
tiens il US parfaitement le la question
que je vous posais c'est l'un de ceux
qui pourrait faire vaciller Gabriel Atal
vous me dites que c'est Emmanuel Macron
qui peut le protéger de ça ou non
c'estàd que là où souvent le président
de la République a quand même à cœur
d'équilibrer les choses et peut faire en
sorte que le premier ministre ne se
sente pas trop les coups des Franches
peut-être qu'on va être dans la
situation où le président de la
République fera des efforts pour
renforcer la position du du Premier
ministre qu'est-ce qui fragilise
beaucoup un premier ministre c'est quand
en fait la moitié de son gouvernement
prend 16 directement va chercher des
arbitrages directement à l'ésée il va
pas y en avoir un certain nombre là dans
ce gouvernement Bruno le ma va-t-il
chercher ses ordres auprès de Gabriel
Atal tiens c'est Marie Lebec nouvelle
ministre qui fait son entrée au
gouvernement on va apprendre à la décou
relation a le Parlement exactement et
c'est une ministre déléguée l'une des
trois ministres déléguées avec pr
porte-parole et Aurore berger également
oui Bruno LEM par exemple géralin
vont-ils voici le ministre de l'Éc
vont-ils prendre leurs ordres auprès de
Gabriel Atal pas certains pas certains
euh on peut même dire que non
honnêtement qu'est-ce qui s'est passé là
depuis depuis le début de la semaine on
visiblement on a donné des gages à l'un
comme à l'autre on les a laissé dire que
pour eux il y avait pas de problème qui
serait reconduit donc on voit bien qu'on
a cherché à quelque part réparer
quelques petites frustrations vexation
qui pouvait y avoir à avoir un jeune
premier ministre dans le cas geréraldin
il faut se rappeler qu'il aurait les se
succèd
pardon première va-t-elle s'éterniser
sur le perron de l'Élysée non pas
vraiment pas autant que Bruno Le Maire
même si elle prend la pause quand même
un sourire elle rentre dans l'Élysée
c'est Bruno Le Maire pour l'instant qui
s'est arrêté le plus longtemps et qui a
dit ce matin quand même pour appuyer
votre propos je le précise qu'il n'y
avait pas de vice-premier ministre je
crois que c'est ça qu'il a dit il veut
affirmer il veut dire que le premier
ministre c'est bien Gabriel oui alors
mais sachant bon le mer est numéro 2
dans l' ordre protocolaire donc quelque
part c'est effectivement une
reconnaissance aussi de son po
gouvernementale donc rapidement Gérald
amanin luouis voyez bien Premier
ministre au mois de de juillet 2022
Bruno Le Maire il a eu Gabriel
Atal quelque part comme ministre auprès
auprès de lui donc c'est effectivement
un tout petit peu potentiellement un
tout petit peu compliqué mais ça va être
un peu à Emmanuel Macron aussi de
remettre un peu de l'ordre ou pas et
s'il veut permettre à son premier
Premier ministre et donc jeune premier
ministre comme on l'a surbondamment
souligné d'assoir son son autorité sur
le gouvernement il devra a priori éviter
qu'il y ait trop de
contournement de la part de ces
ministres les les les les les plus en vu
ce qui va pas être simple he parce qu'
on va quand même s'approcher doucement
et notamment dès le lendemain des
élections européennes qui sont le le 9
juin prochain de la question de la
succession
qui va obséder l'espace politique à
partir du moment o on va se rapprocher
deéchéance de 2027 où Macron Emmanuel
Macron ne peut pas se représenter Stéph
ces journée le nouveau ministre des
Affaires étrangères vient d'entrer dans
le gouvernement on a vu arriver trois
visages un peu moins connus celui de
syvot qui elle reste au gouvernement un
ministre de
l'éducation de l'enseignement supérieur
et Aurore berger en charge de l'égalité
à peu près un mois même Mo à moi syv dit
j'ai présenté ma dimission elle m'a été
refusée ça été vraiment une humiliation
totale qu' ne se retrouve pas quelques
semaines après dans le dans le nouveau
gouvernement on a rappelé que elle avait
manifesté à l'égard notamment d'une des
dispositions de la loi immigration celle
qui consista à demander une caution aux
étudiants étrangers des des netes
réserves oui mais alors c'est l'une des
rares rescapé hein parce que tous les
traîtres bon même si le mot il peut-être
un peu fort euh ne sont plus au
gouvernement on pense à Clément bon on
pense
à Olivier duopt elle malgré ses
réticences elle est restée est-ce
qu'elle est protégée d'une certaine
manière pardon parce que c'est une femme
et que Emmanuel Macron a besoin de femme
dans son gouvernement ça je je ne sais
pas le dire ce qui a présidé à tout cela
après on est quand même sur des des
portefeuilles l'enseignement supérieur
et l'éducation nationale en ferait
partie aussi qui demande un peu de
continuité CT politique dans ce
domaine c'est pas
alors on aurait pu commenter d'ailleurs
la manière dont Gabriel hatal a pris
soin de rappeler quelques réussites
rapides sur des sujets qui traînaient
depuis des années qu'il peut avoir à son
à son palmarès dans le ministère de
l'enseignement supérieur c'est un peu
plus un peu plus compliqué de toute
façon c'est pas non plus une
personnalité symbolique sans lui faire à
jure sylvir taillot par rapport à
d'autres de ceux qui ont exprimé leur
réticence le gouvernement est pas
complètement complètement achevé on a
que la moitié à peu près là donc on
verra il y aura peut-être d'autres
rescap on narrivera pas un gouvernement
resserrer comme le veulent chaque fois
les premier ministres et les président
de la République que plus la majorité
est là elle est un peu est affaiblie
plus les équilibres sont durs à trouver
plus il faut donner des gages aux uns et
aux autres plus on a à cœur aussi de
récompenser les les les fidélités les
les les braves soldats qui à l'Assemblée
ou ailleurs sont de l'aventure depuis le
le début donc voilà la plupart du temps
quand on nous a annoncé un gouvernement
resserré il était resserré qu'au niveau
des ministres de plein exercice et puis
sur la nomination de de ministre délégué
de secrétaire d'État on retrouvait des
gouvernements moins resserrés nous avons
vu arriver Sébastien Lecornu ministre
des armées qui reste à son poste qui a
un temps espéré devenir Premier ministre
h je crois que tous sont arrivés sauf am
caster je sais pas Emmanuel si vous
l'avez vu passer moi j'ai pas vu passer
la nouvelle ministre de
l'Éducation je surveille je vous
surveille sur les images un gouvernement
et ça c'est
évidemment ce qu'on va suivre de près
parce qu'on a parlé beaucoup de
politique politicienne depuis plusieurs
jours de d'équilibre de volonté d' un
peu de politique politicienne dans la
composition du gouvernement aussi oui
juste un
peu un gouvernement qui va va pencher à
droite assez largement avec bon nombre
d'anciens membres de l'UMP d'anciens
sarkozistes plus ou moins est-ce que
cela va se retranscrire dans les fait
parce que maintenant tous ces gens sont
au travail c'est bien beau ces ces
heures là à négocier maintenant il faut
travailler bah ça ça se ça c'est déjà vu
c'estàdire c'est pas nouveau que les
signaux qui sont envoyés sont des
signaux qui parlent davantage à
l'électorat de
droite l'insistance dans le discours
d'Emmanuel de Gabriel àal pardon sur le
Peron de
matigon par je vous coupe un instant
cette caméra qui est en train de courir
selon moi va entrer ouis je pense que
c'est ça souvent lors du premier Conseil
des ministres un gouvernement il y a une
petite photo de famille parfois une
prise de parole de d'Emmanuel Macron
surtout que c'est le premier Conseil des
ministres de l'année donc on va suivre
ça très attentivement et les mots du
président dans ces moment-là sont
particulièrement intéressant je vous
laisse avec ces images qui tremblent je
voulais expliquer pourquoi on on voyait
ça à nos internautes je vous laisse
poursuivre sur ce gouvernement qui pense
la droite ouais il y a un certain nombre
de marqueurs qui ont été qui ont été
donné puis qu y compris sur l'éducation
l'éducation nationale alors on a un
petit peu parlé des élèves décrocheur
mais pas tant que ça notamment à
l'occasion de du dédoublement des
classes enfin de la crrétien de groupe
on a beaucoup parlé de valeurs de
réaffirmer voilà de l'autorité ce
discours auquel Gabriel Atal plus que
Amélie ou ca d'ailleurs a un peu répondu
qui consiste à dire le niveau baisse il
y
a un fléchissement de retrouver un petit
peu voilà le niveau qu'on associé à
différents diplômes il est quand même
plus alors à la fois les générations les
plus âgées et plus ça parle d'avantage
aux électeurs droite les première visite
dans un commissariat ce c'est très bien
les les les les policiers méritent toute
notre estime mais première visiteun d'un
Premier ministre au-delà de de son
déplacement dans dans le la haute France
oui ça peut être dans un hôpital ça peut
être dans alors peut-être pas une école
parce qu'il était lui-même ça ça peut
être dans un centre d'intion social
c'est les les les symboles en fait sont
en général des intentions oui en
revanche vous avez vu qu'il a reçu la
première première entretien du Premier
ministre était avec Marie Lise Léon de
la CFDT
euh donc c'est aussi pour montrer oui
c'est d'ailleurs quelque chose qu'on
trouve possibilités de négociation avec
la gauche récurrente dans les prises de
parole de Gabriel hatal puis c'est
quelquun ai un peu d'amiliie ou Castera
c'est les C intermédiairees oui on y
revient parce que il y a 7 ans en
arrière les corps intermédiaires c'est
pour ça que c'est important de souligner
je crois là on parleéducation nationale
mais on a parlé des présidents des Mair
des présidents de département qui donc
ont en
charge les collèges des présidents rgion
qui s'occupe des lycées les syndicats et
on voit bien qu'il y a cette volonté de
renouer avec l'idée de parler à tout le
monde et donc effectivement les les les
syndicats et la réception de Marie lis
Léon la première secrétaire de la
secrétaire confédérale de de la CFDT est
importante voilà nous sommes toujours en
direct il est 11h09 le premier Conseil
des des ministres du gouvernement àal va
débuter dans un instant on a vu arriver
tous les ministres pour tout ve dire nos
caméras sont pour l'instant en standby
mais on imagine qu'il y aura une
première photo de famille euh à l'Élysée
avec donc Emmanuel Macron Gabriel Atal
et tous ses ministres autour une
passation dépassation ce matin avec une
question qui est revenue souvent la
question des femmes la question
féministe au cœur de ces de ces
passations avec Rachid hadti qui tout de
suite a pris la parole en expliquant
qu'elle
ferait beaucoup de choses visiblement
pour les femmes Catherine Colona qui
elle a dit avoir été la deuxième femme
au ministère des Affaires étrangères
presque avec une petite pique en disant
tiens c'est un homme maintenant de
reprendre le flambeau c'est important
ça alors que Elizabeth borne a quitté le
gouvernement et qu'un homme dirige donc
ce gouvernement oui et que dans l'ordre
protocolaire on va pas trouver beaucoup
on trouve pas beaucoup de femmes dans
dans les dans les premiersres ans donc
il a deux sujets celui-là celui qu'on
vient d'évoquer c'estàdire la place des
femmes dans ce gouvernement et le fait
que Ben après avoir de N nouveau
désigner une femme à Matignon 30 ans
après dit crisson bien ce n'est plus le
cas elle n'a pas été remplacée par une
femme dans le domaine spécifique qui est
celui de rachidati il y a aussi cet
épisode du mois de juin autour de Gérard
pardieu pour le coup n'a pas été très
approuvé par l'opinion publique hein les
enquêtes invitant à se prononcer sur les
réactions de d'Emmanuel Macron sur le
cas de pardieu montrer que ses propos et
sa position n'avait pas été compris oui
nous verrons ce qu'il en est alors ce
qui est intéressant c'est qu'il y a
trois ministres délégués ce sont trois
femmes trois femmes assez jeunes qui
elles sont issu de des rangs de la
macronie hein Marie Lebec pres député
des ivelin voilà Aurore berger est-ce
qu'il y a une volonté peut-être tardive
mais de faire éclore des femmes ça a été
un un problème aussi pour que des femmes
prennent de l'envergure et puissent
prendre des grands ministères il faut
qu'elles aient des postes peut-être
moins importants au début quand elles
sont encore jeunes alors il y a
si on fait exception de Gabriel Atal et
de Stéphane séjourné nommé donc aux
Affaires européennes étrangère il y a
une difficulté à faire
émerger les gens issus de la macronie
aussi Clément B Julien de Normandie
Sébastien Lecornu bon qui est mais c'est
vrai que Al Sébastien lecnu vient de
vient des républicains oui mais avant
avant Emmanuel Macron il était
parfaitement inconnu non le cor nu alors
oui absolument mais ça faisait partie
des des conquêtes mais là les les vous
parliez tout à l'heure l'expression va
très bien des des toliers bah on a donc
Bruno leire ancien LR Gérald amanin
ancien LR et puis marqué par des des des
fonctions ou des parcours assez
importants chez les républicains
s'ajoute Catherine
Vautrin et donc c'est pas non plus un
gouvernement à l'exception encore
évidemment très très très notable de la
nomination de gabrielal à
de promotion euh des de la génération
2017 d'Emmanuel Macron nous verrons si
ces jeunes femmes prennent de de
l'importance selon vous Emmanuel Rivier
lorsqu'on voit la composition de ce
gouvernement où seront les ajustements
par la suite euh
[Musique]
pour m'ajouter un ministre du MoDem à
tel ou tel poste un ministre horizon tel
ou tel poste quels seront les ministères
où il y aura besoin d'avoir du monde et
quels seront les équilibres à nouveau
trouvés
alors on l' évoqué tout à l'heure bah il
y a une question qui est posée sur
l'éducation nationale maire de toutes
les batailles avec un Premier ministre
qui dit je vais continuer à m'enoccuper
mais qui est premier ministre et une
ministre qui dit voilà qui prend le
poste mais qui a les jeux olympique à à
gérer en même temps qu'une qu'une
rentrée donc là il va se présenter va se
présenter évidemment du du renfort euh
Catherine vutrin prenant un grand
ministère des euh
va avoir des ministres des ministres
délégués auès auprès d'elle il y a les
questions du transport du logement sauf
oubli et omission de ma part qui sont
bah des ministères alors don on voit
dont on verra à quel statut on les met
auprès de qui on les met ce qui est pas
une question
anodine il y a la question de l'énergie
et c'est pas simplement qui va s'en
occuper mais où et sous quelle tutelle
ce sera placé puisque alors on on a cru
comprendre que ce serait plutôt oui
plutôt Bruno Le Maire qui s'en chargeit
puisqu'il n'y a plus de ministère de la
planification énergétique occupé par un
espag unch absente surprise de ce
gouvernement on verr on verra ce qui est
proposé à agas pagier runaché ce qui est
en tout cas important dans cette
transition de l'énergie vers Bery c'est
qu'on revient à la situation si je ne
dis pas de bêtises d'avant 2007
c'estàdire avant ce grand ministère
conçu par Alain Jup qui devait le
prendre puis qui a été rattrapé par des
difficultés d'ordre judiciaire qui a
passé la main du
coup et voilà que son nom s'échappe
l'ancien maire de valencien Jean-Louis
borlau Jean-Louis borlot qui a mais qui
a conduit ensuite le Grenel avec ce
ministère qui si je pas encore une fois
comprenait comprenait l'énergie donc ça
ça va être des choses importantes à
suivre effectivement va y avoir un peu
la distribution entre modem horizon
est-ce qu'il y aura d'autres conquêtes
auprès des uns et des autres avec la
question qui se pose là après l'arrivée
de Catherine vautterin et de Rachid
adati qu'on n pas mentionné tout à
l'heure en parlant des figures LR qui
rejoignne le gouvernement est-ce qu'il y
aura des conquêtes dites de gauche euh
pas certain là ça va être difficile de
les convaincre de gauche le dernier en
dat où voilà où assimiler c'était
Patrick vergrit Le Maire de duner qui
avait rejoint le gouvernement au
logement et qui donc fait partie de ces
ministres qui à un moment échangé avec
entre eux et avec la première ministre
sur leur pérénité au gouvernement si la
loi immigration passait nous sommes
toujours en en direct il est 11h15
Emmanuel Rivier merci d'être avec nous
nous avons suivi les différentes
passations de pouvoir ce matin euh les
porte-parole le ministère de la Culture
les affaires étrangères l'éducation
nationale nous avons suivi les arrivées
des différents ministre à l'Élysée ils
viennent de se rendre dans la salle de
de réunion cette grande salle de réunion
où se réunit d'habitude le Conseil des
ministres et nous attendons donc une
image sans doute de ce premier Conseil
des ministres vous êtes spécialiste de
l'opinion Emmanuel Rivière comment
l'opinion prend-il tout cela parce que
maintenant la séquence est passée alors
ça va quand même se poursuivre on en
parlera la semaine prochaine avec les
prises de parole d'Emmanuel Macron et
Gabriel Atal Gabriel Atal devant
l'Assemblée nationale et Emmanuel Macron
nous ne savons pas encore sous quelle
forme
comment l'opinion prend tout cela est-ce
qu'elle est plutôt satisfaite alors ce
qui est intéressant quand on regarde les
sondages qui ont été publé il y a a il y
a de deux sujets il y a la nomination de
Gabriel Atal et puis là il est un peu
tôt pour parler de des effets de la
nomination des uns et des autres au sein
du du gouvernement on
a après la nomination gabrielal
plusieurs sondages qui sont parus où le
niveau de réponse positive sur de
réaction positive va de 37
à 56 % et en disant ça je suis pas en
train de critiquer les sondages je suis
en train de dire non pas vous
évidemment j'étaé très longtemps sondeur
et je ne Renis rien mais je suis en
train de dire c'est sans doute que ce
que ça veut dire c'est que c'est un peu
tôt en fait c'est assez logique et
français son rel 48 % des Français font
confiance à Gabriel Atal bon c'est à peu
près ça c'est une moyenne juste en
dessous des 50 % C on va dire cette la
moyenne entre les deux les deux extrêmes
que je viens de citer mais ça dépend
surtout beaucoup dans la manière don
d'ailleurs sont conçus ces sondages à
quel point on laisse aux gens la
possibilité de dire et au fond c'est ce
qu'il pense il est trop tôt pour juger
oui euh donc là où on voit des symboles
des des
marqueur un sens donner à beaucoup de
gens disent ben déjà voyant ce qu'il va
faire h et ça peut prendre du temps
avant de dire si on est satisfait pas
satisfait je pense que ce sera un peu la
même chose avec le gouvernement sauf que
ce qui sera intéressant de suivre voyez
j'invite aussi à regarder les sondages
c'est voir comment les cotes de
popularité d'image de confiance tout ce
que vous voulez des personnalités qui
sont promu nommées évoluent avec parfois
justement l'accession à un poste
ministériel si on réussit au moment de
son intronisation à passer quelques
messages clés qui font écho aux
préoccupations de l'opinion parfois ça
crée une une espèce plusvalue sondagiare
qui montre que là tiens celui-là ou
celle-là on a remarqué qu'il était
rentré au gouvernement promis au
gouvernement dans une position
particulière mais encore une fois le le
fond de la politique faut pas l'oublier
pour les gens c'est qu'est-ce qui se
passe vraiment qu'est-ce qui se passe
sur le pouvoir d'achat qu'est-ce qui va
se passer dans l'école de mes enfants
est-ce queà la prochaine rentrée il y
aura des profs absentsprès des profs
absents qu'est-ce qui va se passer sur
la possibilité de prendre un rendez-vous
chez le médecin qu'est-ce qui se passe
quand on va aux urgences est-ce que j'ai
accès au service public des des des
décisions politique c'est on dit souvent
que dans le dernier kilomètre les
Français ne la bénéficient pas vraiment
c'est pour ça qu'il va être
intéressant avait été nommé notamment
pour ça bon et aussi avec une dimension
très territoire Gabriel va être
intéressant il a dit hier sur TF1 qu'il
voulait des actes des actes des actes
c'est vrai qu'il a réussi Rud Grenel ce
qui explique d'ailleurs dans votre
baromètre le baromètre du Figaro
Magazine avec avec ver pendant qu'il
était Rud Grenel ce qui ne s'est pas du
tout produit pendant toute la période où
il était ministre des comptes publics
pourquoi parce qu'il a comme il l'a
rappelé d'ailleurs lors de sa passation
de de pouvoir avec Amélie ou et ca
réaliser un certain nombre de choses
réaliser c'est pas dire juste dire oh là
là il y a un problème c'est il y a un
problème je le résous et c'est immédiat
la reconquête du mois de juin rebasculer
une partie des examens de spécialité du
baccalauréat en fin d'année et non plus
au mois de mars répondait surtout la B
c'est ça mais alors ça j'y crois pas du
tout surtout la BA vous me parlez ah oui
vous allez m'expliquer pourquoi mais
vous me parlez de d'acte
immédiat c'est parfois difficile
d'imaginer reconquérir le mois de juin
en plein mois de novembre difficile de
l'expliquer et de le montrer de voir si
ça marche vraiment alors que la du jour
au lendemain reconquérir le mois de juin
ça parle croyez-moi à tous les parents
d'enfant scolarisés qui ont eu des
enfants dont il savaient pas quoi faire
au mois de juin qui disaient mais
pourquoi mon enfant qu'est-ce que pas
encore t voyez ce que je veux dire la
BAA du jour au lendemain elle est
interdit point il y a pas de discussion
c'est pour ça que je comprends pas là là
on est plus dans sybole parce que la
baaya ça doit être je pense qu'il y en a
dans moins de 1 centiè des
établissements scolaires donc là c'est
alors mais de fait c'est quelque chose
qui parle aussi pas forcément aux
parents d'élèves et à mon avis plus
directement un électorat qui est
préoccupé par ces questions qui sont des
questions d'identité et de perception
d'une menace sur ce qui fait l'identité
le vivre ensemble en France et notamment
sur la question des des des symboles
religieux pour le dire clairement issu
de la religion euh la religion musulmane
he parce qu'on faut pas se tromper la la
la laïcité quand quand elle devient une
valeur unanimement partagée de la gauche
de la gauche à la droite de la droite en
partie euh c'est aussi par rapport à par
rapport à à cela et à la place supposée
de de la religion musulmane mais de fait
la BAA a étéit un moment salué aussi euh
pour pour Gabriel Atal pas que ça he
c'estes réactions immédiate sur la
question du harcèlement
euh ce qui euh
l' aussi distinguer sur un côté un peu
un peu un peu émotionnel donc ça va être
aussi l'articulation de cela c'estàd sa
capacité à réagir sur des choses qui
créent de l'émotion qui créent des
inquiétudes et puis à obtenir des
résultats encore je parlais de du du du
mois de juin euh bah c'est quand même
même si ça n'est pas encore arrivé c'est
assez facile pour tout le monde de se
dire bah les épreuves
anticipées pour mon enfant qui est en
seconde en première en terminale au lieu
d'avoir lieu au mois de mars ce sera au
mois de au mois de juillet je crois ou
au mois de juin et puis ce qui va être
au mois de juillet c'est le brevet des
collèges ça je pense que ça parle tout
de suite comme étant une une réalisation
concrète et immédiate est-ce qu'il y
aura un un état de grâce pour pour
Gabriel Atal
il y en a de moins en moins oui c'est
vrai que on dit toujours il est 100
jours l'état de grâce parce que lui va
en bénéficier il part très haut dans les
sondages oui mais l'état de grâce pour
le coup ça fonctionne pas trop mal au
moment de la conquête du pouvoir par le
Président de la République avec la
nomination de son premier Premier
ministre là on a en général un moment
d'état de de grâce qui est aéé par la
victoire la reconquête du pouvoir par
Emmanuel Macron a absolument rien
produit dans le l' opinion de ce qu'on
constate habituellement au lendemain
d'une élection présidentielle mais c'est
parce que c'est la première
réélection sans cohabitation bien sûr
tout court d'ailleurs parce que d'une
certaine manière en 1965 le général le
GA n'avait pas été réélu au suffrage
universel mais élu au suffrage universel
de sa désignation 58 étant par le
Parlement donc on n pas eu d'état de
grâce c'est quand un premier ministre s
changé en cours de mandat c'est alors je
pense que Gabriel Atal va démarrer plus
haut oui
que ellisabeth borne car son image était
meilleure tout simplement parce qu'il il
part de son socle de popularité et le
nommé comme étant une des personnalités
préférées des Français ça avait été le
cas de Manuel Vals en 2014 qui démarrait
plus haut nettement plus haut que
Jean-Marc HUD pour Manuel Vals la
popularité s'est été érodée assez alors
justement c'est peut-être un souci pour
une personnalité politique de partir
aussi l'effet waou comme on le dit
depuis de jours c'est la première fois
finalement depuis 7 ans depuis
l'élection d'Emmanuel Macron qu'il y a
autant d'attente d'une certaine manière
autour d'un d'une personnalité politique
est-ce qu'on peut vite déchanter être
vite déçu et que la popularité de
Gabriel Atal s'effondre on sait que ce
poste de Premier ministre il a plutôt
tendance à faire baisser la courbe de
popularité que la faire grimper bah ça
va se passer sur des choses encore assez
assez concrètes c'estd les les les gens
restent très très préoccupés par
l'inflation et par leur par leur pouvoir
d'achat euh va y avoir une échéance qui
va arriver pas très très loin de des
élections européennes c'est le moment où
les gens et notamment au sein de
l'électorat actuel dans de enfin
d'Emmanuel Macron de renaissance ça
compte c'est les les feuilles d'impôts
je veux faire baisser les impôts pour
les classes moyennes quand on dit ça au
moment de son intronisation les gens
regarde leur feuille d'impôt au mois de
de juin et voit ce que ce qu'il en est
donc là il peut y avoir des
satisfactions ou euh des euh ou des
déceptions et puis il y a tout ce qui
n'est pas une image pardon qui nous
arrive à l'instant c'est une image
enregistré je le précise il n'y a pas eu
d'image en direct mais voici donc ce
premier Conseil des ministres resserré
la table est petite hein vous avez vu
d'habitude c'est une longue table c'est
une longue table il y a pas de carré
comme ça au milieu à droite d'Emmanuel
Macron Bruno leemer à sa gauche
Catherine Varin et donc en face Gabriel
Atal avec à ses côtés Amélie oua
casterra et Gérald Darman l'ordre
protocolaire est respecté euh
visiblement plus on est proche du
président oui de toute façon la table du
Conseil ministre c'est toujours ça
président de la République en face du
premier ministre et puis ensuite en
fonction protocolaire on s'échelonne et
puis on est quand on est bah sur les
côtés c'est qu'on est moins bien placé
dans l'ordre dans l'ordre protocolaire
donc c'est vrai que c'est un premier
Conseil des
ministres voilà important vous disiez
tout à l'heure qu'il y aurait pas de
compte-rendu du de ce premier Conseil
des minist non euh nous verrons ça
étonnant d'ailleurs bon peut-être qu'il
n'y a pas de grands projets qui seront
lancés d aujourd'hui on est encore dans
les tractations politiques à savoir qui
seront les secrétaires d'État les
ministres délégués oui puis a il y a
enfin il a il y a quelques grands
moments qui sont censés se
pro produire dans les jours qui viennent
déclaration de de politique générale de
la part du du du nouveau premier minist
termine par ça d'ailleurs Gabriel Atal
va se rendre devant les députés c'est
mardi pour prononcer son son discours de
politique générale c'est une obligation
ce qui n'est pas obligatoire c'est de se
soumettre au vote de confiance va-t-il
le faire doit-il le faire on se rappelle
qu'Élisabeth borne ne s'y était pas
soumise pour ne pas prendre le risque
d'être destitué hein très rapidement
pour une raison simple Emmanuel Macron
et le gouvernement n'ont pas de majorité
à l'Assemblée nationale est-ce qu'il
doit le faire est-ce qu'il va le faire
alors ce qui est apparu quand même au
moment notamment du vote de rejet h ce
vote majoritaire à l'Assemblée nationale
qui en gros dit nous ne souhaitons pas
discuter de la loi immigration c'est
qu'apparemment la tentation était forte
pour les groupes d'opposition dans une
motion de rejet d'ailleurs qui était
porté par Europe Écologie Les ver peutre
ça aurait pas été la même chose si c
avait été celle portée par le
rassemblement national ou la France
insoumise qui avait été sélectionné
tirer au sort on voit bien que la la la
tentation est forte quand même et au
moment de vote de non pas du vote de la
loi sur la retraite pardon de la motion
de censure consécutive à l'utilisation
du 493 c'était passé à ne9u voix près
donc je pense que deux fois le vent du
boulet est passé assez
près et donc beaucoup plus près que
lorsque en 2022 le choix avait été fait
de ne pas recourir à à un vote de de
confiance donc là ce serait mettre à la
main des oppositions la tentation de
mettre à bat tout de suite le le château
de carte Pass vous pensez qu'il ne le
fera pas et qu'il ne devrait pas le
faire alors
même la gauche a clairement dit qu'il
voterait en défveur évidemment en
revanche LR et RN ont dit qu'à priori a
priori il n'y aurait pas de raison de
voter contre voilà ce que disent pour
l'instant les les oppositions autre
question et ce sera ma dernière Emmanuel
Rivière Emmanuel Macron a annoncé qu'il
prendrait la parole son entourage
annoncé il prendrait la parole de quelle
manière avant ou après Gabriel Atal ça
aussi on parlait tout à l'heure de le
protéger l'attitude qu'il aura avec lui
ça c'est important on va le surveiller
B là je je rappelais tout à l'heure hein
c'est pas anodin que un premier ministre
a été aussi longtemps sous l'autorité du
du président de la République c'est
enfin le cadre d'Édouard philippe était
diamétralement opposé c'estàdire
queéedouard Philippe n'était pas
connu Gabri est connu Édouard Philippe
venait du camp qui avait affronté
Emmanuel Macron principal concurrent
d'Emmanuel Macron au premier tour de la
présidentielle qui était les
républicains Gabriel Atal est un fidèle
depuis le le début il Suu la gauche donc
et puis pu en 2017 tout tourna autour
d'Emmanuel Macron on se préoccupa assez
peu de son premier ministreut rappeler
et là une une des questions d'ailleurs
qui va de plus en plus se poser je vis
pas la poser de manière anticipée encore
une fois les Français là aujourd'hui ils
veulent être gouvern ils veulent qu'on
apporte des solutions à leurs principaux
problèmes dans le de l'éducation du
pouvoir
d'achat mais la question qui va assez
rapidement se poser c'est est-ce que
Emmanuel Macron a choisi un successeur
et va vouloir lui tendre l'échelle et
faciliter son sa sa succession et son
accession au pouvoir ou est-ce que
Emmanuel Macron voudra pouvoir gouverner
et avoir une autorité jusqu'au bout
quelqu'un plutôt permettre à plusieurs
successeurs dans une dans une stratégie
qui consiste à à diviser pour pour mieux
régner et on va lui faire le procès
d'atention pour penser qu'il ferait
partie de ses dirigent qui se diraient
après moi déluge à la limite j'aime
autant que ce soit quelqu'un du du camp
d'en face qui soit mais on sait
qu'Emmanuel Macron en tout cas il y a un
scénario qui un scénario qui serait
plutôt le cauchemar c'est l'accession de
Marine Le Pen à la présidence de la
République ce qui signerait un échec en
fait de ces 10 ans de pouvoir c'est je
vous entends mais en éant en étant
parfaitement cynique on peut aussi
imaginer qu'emu Macron voudra revenir au
pouvoir en 2032 voyez tout est
imaginable et pour revenir au pouvoir en
2032 il en a le droit de se représenter
puisque un président n'a pas le droit
d'être élu deux fois
consécutivement il serait plus favorable
d'avoir l'opposition au pouvoir pendant
5 ans voyez on peut toujours imaginer
alors là on parle à 8 ans donc on en est
très loin mais bon je suis pas sûr que
tout ça soit écrit en fait et que donc
là comme on le fait d'ailleurs depuis
juin 2 20 où on invente en marchant et
très souvent trébuchant ce que c'est que
de gouverner sans majorité et sans avoir
cherché à en constituer une là tout ça
répond à sans doute des présupposés des
des des idées que ça pourra bien
fonctionn Gabriel hatal est-ce qu'il a
vocation à être Premier ministre jusque
à l'élection 2027 ou pas après tout il
reste toujours un premier ministre Paris
qui briguerait en 2026 par pour la Paris
j'ai l'impression qu'il se dessine un
autre
scénnario je reviens à ma question
originale va-t-il parler avant ou après
Gabriel Atal la semaine prochaine plutôt
après non moi j'ai vraiment j'ai pas
qu'une compétence pour avoir la réponse
à tout ça je pense que ça va être en
fonction de tout ce qu'on vient de se
dire c'estàd qu'est-ce qu'il veut faire
pour Gabriel Atal est-ce qu'il veut le
renforcer renforcer son autorité le
conforter dans son rapport de force avec
les poids lourds qui sont censé être
sous son autorité que sont Gérard L ou
Bruno Le Maire ou est-ce qu'il va
vouloir rappeler que tout ça c'est quand
même sa vision son impulsion Emmanuel
Macron et que donc bah oui Gabriel Atal
c'est quelqu'un de son équipe c'est
quelque part un collaborateur et donc
rappeler la hiérarchie entre lui et son
nouveau Premier ministre donc c'est
c'est c'est vraiment les deux scénarios
à mon avis ont tous tous les deux leur
validité merci beaucoup Emmanuel Rivière
c'était ça le grand rendez-vous avec les
Français promis par Emmanuel Macron nous
sommes le 12 janvier ù il il y aura
autre chose une autre annonce je pense
enfin je pense pas qu'un remaniement
puisse être à la hauteur de l'expression
grand rendez-vous avec la la nation
attendez plutôt autre chose bon
et ça a été un peu un moment murmuré
qu'en fait il y aurait une série ce
rendez-vous serait décliné sous la forme
d'une série d'initiatives donc on verra
bien ce qu'il en est merci beaucoup
Emmanuel Rivière spécialiste de
l'opinion directeur associé de l'agence
grand public merci de nous avoir aidé à
décrypter cette matinée de passation de
pouvoir avec euh plusieurs faits
intéressants la prise de parole euh tout
à l'heure de Rachid hadti pour sa
première au ministère de de la culture
un ton très grave très solennel on a
aussi suivi la passation de pouvoir
assez particulière très différente des
autres au ministère de l'Éducation
nationale c'est Gabriel tal qui a fixé
le cap finalement à Amélie oua Castera
qui a pris la parole ensuite nous
verrons dans quelques minutes mais pour
l'instant ce n'est pas prévu si un
contrendu de ce conseil des ministres
qui est en train de se tenir aura bien
lieu pour l'instant non merci de nous
avoir suivi on reste ensemble cet
après-midi pour suivre les derniers
développements autour de ce nouveau
gouvernement